Gabor,
welcome to the show.
Tim is a great pleasure to be here.
Thank you.
I have been looking forward to this conversation for a really long time and I
wanted to make an attempt at least to do it right,
so I want it to have the video and the audio and everything else because I think
the work you're doing is very important and we're going to cover a lot of
ground,
which I'm very excited to cover because I think it's a real contribution and you
have tools and frameworks can really help people.
I thought we might start with books and the reason I thought that could be a fun
place to start.
My audience loves books,
Number One,
but number two in tribe of mentors.
Last book that I wrote or that my guest wrote,
you were featured and I thought that many of the books you mentioned paint a
picture of your life experience and also your life's work in many ways.
And we can go in any particular order,
but I thought maybe it would make sense to start with the scourge of the
swastika.
And that was one that you mentioned had had an impact on you or that perhaps you
recommended on occasion.
Why is that?
Well,
so this has to do with my family's history.
I grew up,
was born in Budapest,
Hungary in 1944 in January,
two months before the Germans occupied the country,
and Hungary at that time was the only country in eastern Europe where the Jewish
population had not been annihilated.
And that was our turn.
So it was two months of age.
The day after the German army marched into Budapest,
my mother phoned the pediatrician to say,
would you please come and see God?
Boy,
of course he's crying all the time.
And the Peter Just said,
of course I will come,
but I should tell you all my Jewish babies of her crying.
And of course that's the infant speaking up on their mother's terror and stress.
And that's how I spent the first year of my life.
We just had a huge impact on my development and my lifelong struggles with
depression and Adhd,
uh,
self shame and,
and other issues.
Jumping ahead now I knew very little about that history and my parents didn't
say much about it as I was growing up.
I knew my grandparents had been killed in Auschwitz.
I knew my father had been enforced labor and I never saw him for a year and a
half.
But beyond that,
I knew not much about the details until I was about nine or 10 maybe 11 years
old.
And there was a book on my parent's shelf in Budapest with the title,
the scourge of the swastika,
which was where it wasn't by a British civil servant and a member of the House
of Lords.
This man has served at the British army and he was the first book published in
the 50s that detailed the Nazi crimes.
And I climbed up on a chair,
took the,
on the book when I was,
I think 10 or 11,
began to read it.
So photographs of the horrors of the concentration camps and the extermination
details and eastern Europe.
And all of a sudden I swooned cause I got what happened to my family and that
question of how can people do such things to other human beings,
which strike me every day.
And an almost every this thought occurred to me for years and years and years on
almost every day almost got dizzy with the question.
So why people suffer and my people make other people suffer.
And what is the original?
All that has been a motivating question in our life.
So that's what,
that book was so important to me.
Thank you.
And I have to say that,
you know,
my life's work has been motivated by that question.
As a,
as a medical doctor,
um,
I'm always looking at,
well,
what is it that makes people be the way they are?
Why did we come cruel?
Why to become victims.
Um,
why did it become perpetrators?
What drives us?
What kind of insanity covers our basic human nature,
which I believe to be good and uh,
and then positive and what happens to us.
We're going to spend a lot of time in that territory for sure.
Okay.
So you mentioned sanity or insanity.
I'm not sure if that's a good segue to don Quixote,
but I'll let you choose the next one.
So there are a few that came up and you described them brief
in the pages of the book,
but for instance,
the back end that you just gave me,
it was much more in depth.
So we have a few,
and these are going to strike folks as eclectic.
Winnie the Pooh,
the Dhammapada,
the drama of the gifted child and Don Quixote.
Which one of those would you like to explain?
School is one of the pool.
Let's go with Winnie the Pooh.
Yeah.
So that was one of the seminal books of my childhood and my parents would have
read to me long before I even knew how to read the hunger.
And title is Mitzi much coal.
And uh,
it was translating Moscow,
Mitzi Matsko,
uh,
Mitzi the bear.
And,
uh,
the translator is a great hunger and humorist.
So if anything,
the Hungarian book is even funnier than the original English,
which is not something when usually says about translations.
But what struck me about pool of course,
was number one,
that there was this bear of little brains who assault some of so much wiser than
everybody else.
So fundamental,
you found a piece inside despite the fact that his intellect is just under
functioning.
Uh,
number one.
Number two,
there was this relationship with the little boy,
um,
uh,
Christopher Robin,
and there's a passage towards the end of the book where Christopher Robin,
I don't know if you know the real story,
in fact,
there's a movie,
there's a movie about it right now,
but,
but Christopher Robin,
his father AML was a writer and he bought these toys for his son to make stories
about them.
And Christopher Robin actually suffered because he was secondary to his father's
career.
They did not have a good relationship.
So these characters at the father,
the me made up kind of dominated and squeezed out.
Christopher rob his own life and he himself became a bookseller later on his
life and he wrote about his autobiography.
So there's something about the the dysfunctionality and father son relationship.
But in the book,
Christopher is playing with his toys and then he starts to grow up and he has to
go to school and he won't be able to play with his toys anymore.
And at the very end of the book,
there's a passage where
the book ends with,
but whatever they go in the enchanted forest,
a little boy has barrier,
will always be playing together.
And that would just bring tears to my eyes for decades upon decades upon decades
until recently I had a,
an experience,
but she,
a psychedelic experience when I realized that does nothing to mourn because I'm
both the bear and the little boy and I was,
we'll be playing that.
Nothing is lost.
But when I read that book,
there was a sense of loss.
When I read that passage though,
something's being lost.
Childhood innocence is being lost.
Playfulness is being lost,
which resonated with my own shot because I did lose innocence and then
playfulness very early in life.
So both for the fun and the humor.
Then of course there's ie or for whatever
thing always goes badly.
And as a part of me that's totally,
or I was expecting the worst and nothing will ever work out for me and
nevermind,
leave me alone.
I'm okay with my own suffering.
You know that that's sort of determined victim attitude.
That was also very much Germane to my inner experience.
So that book just spoke to me and made me laugh.
And it still does.
It's one of the funniest books that are written in one of the wisest as well.
I need to,
I've only,
I,
I'm ashamed to say this,
but I've only seen the cartoon,
so I,
I know,
I know.
Well,
listen,
one of the sins that,
well,
Disney is going to be burning in hell for the rest of existence is what he did
with those.
The stories I was at Disney fight them,
dignified them.
You,
you,
you got to read the original and you,
you would laugh
your head off.
Guys,
I'm in,
I'm in.
I wish I spoke Hungarian so I could read the translation.
Uh,
which of these would you like to,
and we can certainly touch on other books,
but so we have three,
three remaining on my list and Dhammapada the drama of the gifted child and
donkey Wooten.
Well,
let's go to the drama of the gifted child.
Said the drama of the gifted child is by a Swiss German Jewish Swiss
psychotherapist named Alice Miller,
who was for three decades a psychoanalyst.
But she realized that the Floridians Psychedelic psychonautic method wasn't
helping anybody get better because it ignored.
So the drama of the gifted child,
the German title of a bitch was prisoners of childhood was really all about the
fact that stuff happens to us as children.
Negative things happen.
Then we adapt to those things.
By taking on certain defensive ways of being and then we'll leave the rest of
our lives from those defensive modes.
So we're not actually experiencing the present.
We're constantly reliving the past from a perspective that we acquired when we
were helpless and vulnerable children.
And when she says the gift to charge him is a sensitive child.
So the more sensitive the child is,
the more he or she feels the pain and stress of the environment and the more
effective they are and the more that shapes their lives.
And that book came along for me when I was in my forties and I was a successful
doctor and,
and,
and uh,
and I was a father,
but I was depressed.
I was anxious,
I was a driven workaholic.
You wouldn't have known that when you saw me on the job.
But inside me,
I was discouraged.
I had difficulties in my marriage with my children.
I felt they were afraid of me and they were because of my religious.
And that book helped me understand.
It was the first book to help me understand where all that came from.
So that was for me as for many of the people the Seminole read and really my
whole work since then has been to help liberate people from that prison.
The childhood often imposes on so many of us.
This book has come up repeatedly in my life as a recommendation,
as a recommended book from friends who benefited from it are very certainly from
any outward perspective,
highly functioning.
Yeah.
In some cases,
world class performers in their fields and uh,
I'm
okay
in retrospect.
Okay.
Sad that I ignored those recommendations,
but it was in part because I didn't like the pairing of gifted child.
I didn't want to label myself gifted child.
We could certainly say psychoanalyze that,
but I was like,
hmm,
if this is a book written for people who are in,
say,
gifted and talented programs or have some God given talent for whatever reason,
I had a resistance to that,
so I didn't read it.
But the prisoners of childhood makes a lot more sense to me anyway.
I think it's a more accurate title,
but there's two things I would say in response.
First of all,
why do you resist you?
I'm giftedness.
You clearly gifted.
So why would you not want to find out about that?
Don't know.
Yeah.
So that's,
that's something you might want to consider.
Sure.
A number one.
Number two,
really what she means is the sensitive child.
Yeah.
So sensitive that would draw me in because I've had,
we don't have to necessarily go down this rabbit hole right now,
but I've had a number of my friends recently asked me,
when did,
you know,
you were so sensitive and not sensitive in a,
in a hyper reactive way,
not in a negative way,
just in a perceptive way.
And I'd never thought of myself,
it would never have occurred to me to label myself sensitive.
And it just,
in the last year I've been thinking about that.
So this,
the sensitive child would make,
make more,
uh,
more sensor would be more appealing.
Well,
you have to think of sensitive in terms of his word,
origin of the word sensitive.
Kim's from the Latin word,
sincere to feel so sensitive person feels more.
Yeah.
So the example I often give is,
and that can lead to both very positive and very difficult.
Uh,
um,
consequences.
For example,
if I tapped you on the shoulder right now,
you wouldn't feel any pain at all.
But if you're not wearing your shirt and your skin was exposed for the Murphy at
a burn on your shoulders,
so your nerve endings are close to the surface.
If I tagged you with the same force,
you'd feel extreme,
excruciating pain even though the external event was no different.
Right?
So sensitivity magnifies the pain that we have.
Sensitivity also leads to more creativity.
So very often the most creative people also have the most pain,
which is my,
so many creative people escape from their pain through all kinds of
dysfunctions,
like addictions and so on.
So there's a real link between creativity and sensitivity and creativity and,
and,
and sensitivity and suffering at the same time.
That's the first point I would make.
Now the other thing goes back to what you said about these people that you know,
who are high performers.
Look at that word,
performers.
What does it mean to perform?
One meaning of it is to put on a show.
Sure.
That's for meaning.
And I would have been one of those people who was a high performer.
Uh,
in other words,
look,
that's from the outside successful,
funny doctor,
direct of a palliative care unit at a major hospital,
national columnist for Canadian newspaper,
writing medical columns,
performing at a high level and inside.
Okay.
Again,
anxious,
frustrated,
depressed,
discouraged,
and in my personal life,
a lot of suffering.
So a lot of people who perform well,
okay
are actually deeply troubled inside.
And of course there's many famous examples of that.
Some of the greatest performers like Presley or Marilyn Monroe and any number of
people like the name,
that's what they were,
they were performers.
And even from themselves,
they hid their own suffering.
Well,
we're sitting in a venue right now recording this that is now known as LCR.
And there was a mural of prince outside because he performed his,
as I understand it,
last performance in this venue or really before he passed away and before you
overdosed,
before you overdosed.
Yeah,
exactly.
And we can certainly come back to this.
But part of the reason I wanted to,
big piece of the reason I want it to have you on the show was that I spent,
I'm in a much better place now for many reasons that may be outside of this
interview,
but uh,
feeling the exact same way you just described.
Yeah.
Outwardly successful in Ridley tortured.
And
how do you answer the question?
If someone meets you and you just have a short interaction,
what do you do?
What do I,
if someone asks you,
yeah,
what do you do?
Okay.
Yeah.
I may maybe self serving,
but somebody once called me a people whisperer.
People whisper.
Aye.
Okay.
Do you have a gift for seeing inside?
Cause I've studied,
I'm also sensitive and in some ways,
and I've also studied myself very deeply.
I've had to,
because my real life just wasn't working.
And as a medical doctor I've worked with,
all men are of conditioners,
terminal diseases,
newborns,
families,
physical illnesses,
mental dysfunction.
As I spent 12 years working with addictions,
I spent on exploring my own and other people's Adhd.
And so I
work with people to bring a to the truth of their experience so that they're no
longer prisoners of their childhood,
but that they can make a conscious choice about how to live in the present
moment,
not based on how they were probably in chartered.
And,
but for that you have to do it in a way that the dog we're spirit do in a very
compassionate way.
Otherwise people just shut down and,
and,
and they,
they shrivel up and they protect themselves.
So that's what I do.
And I know I also write and I speak publicly and so on,
but the intent is always to bring insight and liberation to people.
So I'm going to come back to the medicine makes,
I'd love to know when your journey into medicine began,
but first,
since I know my listeners will say,
but you forgot the other two books,
what about the other two books,
the Dhammapada Don Quixote in any order you like?
Well,
let's go in the order that I discovered them,
which is don Quixote,
which again,
I read that as a child and then reread many times as an adult.
And he's my favorite character.
So Quixote is this,
um,
diluted Spanish,
small noble man who wants to revive the age of chivalry and chivalry knighthood.
So he guessed is broken down a horse called Rosie Dante,
and he is lance and his sword and is he gets this,
uh,
squire called Sachio Panza on his donkey and off they go off to these adventures
and he does not see reality.
He thinks windmills are giants and he attacks them.
And of course he gets hurt and he keeps getting hurt cause cause he doesn't see
reality.
He,
but his heart is purely committed to liberating people to truth,
to justice,
to,
uh,
fighting a oppressors,
to liberating the oppressed.
So here's this guy who really wants to do good in the world and he's just
diluted in his vision,
but he's far too her and deeper and more human than all the people that scoff at
him and laugh at him.
So what a great character.
And the book is both poignant and very funny,
and,
uh,
it's,
he's one of the great creations of world literature.
And of course,
again,
you know,
that yearning for justice,
uh,
has always burned in my heart,
willing to what happened to me.
And what I witnessed
in the double Pata,
the demo plot is the Buddhist collection of sayings.
And it begins with a,
basically the idea that we create the world with our minds.
He says,
everything is thought in the lead.
So how we see the world,
uh,
it's Ho is,
determines the world that we live in.
So if I see the world as a horrible place coding the current president of the
United States,
then I will be defensive and grandizing and selfish cause I want to take before
they take from me,
I want to attack before I got attacked.
I'll always will be to look at it for myself because the role is not to be
trusted.
So if that's the word you live in and that's the way you're going to create,
um,
and the Buddha was great psychologist and be to recognize that our perception
shaped the world that we live in.
Now what he didn't say,
and that's where modern psychology comes in,
is that before with our mind,
we create the world.
The world creates our minds.
So that the,
the,
the kind of world that we live in is very much shaped by early experiences.
What I didn't say that,
but interestingly enough,
when you think of what his search for truth,
um,
what happened to him,
if you read his biography,
his mother died before he was a week old.
So He's lost his most important relationship.
So his life began with suffering and then he spent all his life trying to
find the nature of suffering and how to transcend suffering and how to get
beyond it.
And this is how he,
um,
uh,
ended up with this particular method of meditation and Contemplation and truth
seeking.
So that book was written 20,
2,500 years ago and psychologically we're still catching,
trying to catch up to the wisdom in it.
So let's talk about wisdom or perhaps science first.
And maybe they're related in some fashion,
although I know we'll,
we'll,
we'll dig into certainly some things that might be missing.
When did medicine into your life or an interest in medicine interest in being a
doctor?
Either of those things?
Well,
I've speculated on that and um,
there's a number of sources,
strangely enough or necessarily engine of my grandfather who was killed in
Auschwitz in his 50s happened to be a,
and a doctor Grantson ends up as a writer and a doctor.
So I think part of it was me trying to fill the hole in my mother's life.
Hmm.
That was a devastating blow to her.
This is not conscious,
but I'm speculating,
looking back,
it's not that she ever said you have to become a doctor.
It's not that she ever said you have to follow in your grandfather's footsteps.
But I think that consciously I stepped into that role,
number one.
Number two.
Um,
and other reason is that is a June is two in Europe you had every reason to feel
insecure and my mother never failed to tell me that as a doctor you carry your
profession and your hands.
So you don't have to have a business,
you don't have to have riches,
you just have to have the knowledge.
And then you can go anywhere in the world and you'll be okay.
Beyond that healing and,
and,
and making this world a better place and have people help people lead healthy
lives was just an ideal of mine.
Then it was like with testicle reasons.
Uh,
let's face it,
doctors get respect.
They ever vole they have a good income.
People look up to them and they have a sense of authority that I think I lacked
in my own life.
So it was a combination of unconscious reasons and,
and,
and idealistic reasons and they go just tickle reasons.
Uh,
but,
but all I know is that all my life I had wanted to be nothing else but a doctor.
I always grew up knowing I'd be a physician.
And when you were studying medicine,
what did you think your specialty or specialties might be?
Well,
first of all,
I should say,
I didn't end up following the dream because,
uh,
I,
in my late teens I just couldn't concentrate and study hard enough to get
through the sciences.
I could get through them,
but I couldn't get the high marks needed to get the medical school.
So actually taught high school for three years.
I taught English and history for three years and then I would wake up and,
and,
and these voice in me,
you got to be a doctor,
but I'd be a doctor.
And so then I went back to medical school.
And a lot of hard work,
um,
are having been an older student in medical school and being interested in
history and literature and the larger picture,
I always wanted to put medicine in the context of history,
in the context of society,
in the context of human experience,
not just as an isolated science,
what does as part of the broader human experience.
And I was interested right away from the,
in the beginning between the,
in the connections between emotions and illness,
between social factors and health and so on.
And so I was always a larger picture of person.
Uh,
and so that is,
that was with me already in medical school.
So the integration of mind and body as opposed to the sort of Cartesian duality
and separation of my new buddy.
Exactly.
Not that anything in medical school prepared me for that.
I mean,
in medical school you just don't get that at all.
But that was always my interest.
And then when I started practicing,
if your eyes are at all open,
you just can't,
you can't help but to see it,
the,
the who gets sick and who doesn't isn't accidental and who gets cancer because
it doesn't,
isn't accidental then who gets addicted and who doesn't isn't accidental.
And then there was this reasons and those reasons school beyond the individual
and it has to do with their emotional lives and our relationships and the
society and the culture that they live in.
So more and more over the decades,
my own personal struggles and my medical experience showed me that these
connections are important.
How did you end up in Palliative care?
And,
uh,
I suppose for those people listen to,
you don't know what palliative care is.
Perhaps you could give just a brief explanation of what that is.
Some people might think of it as hospice care,
uh,
which is,
which I'm not sure,
I don't think are necessarily identical,
but well,
how did you end up,
what was the road to palliative care and what is palliative care?
So I was a family physician and a very driven one.
And I'm also have the,
which means that you want to move around and have this and experiences,
you know,
cause you get tired of the same thing.
And it was really in retrospect,
I might say that there's some guidance in all this,
but how it occurred was a series of accidents.
So I've happened to be walking down the hall of Vancouver's Major Hospital when
the current director of Palliative Care said,
I'm quitting.
I would you like to come and work in Palliative care?
And I said,
sure.
You know,
I didn't think it took me a not a moment to think about it.
He was just looking for someone to grab,
got palliative care.
Sure.
Thank you.
What is that?
And a deeply meaningful work,
uh,
because when people are facing death,
they also come up against the truth of their lives.
And,
and,
uh,
if you can face death,
you can face life
in palliative care,
meaning you're helping people to transition with terminal illness.
These are people for whom nothing curative or,
or,
or healing is going to happen in the sense of physical healing.
So they need to be helped with their symptoms,
with their pain or the ability or weakness or nausea.
But also you have to have to help them go through the,
the psychological process of adjusting to a very short future.
And,
uh,
the people that get daunted,
palliative care work,
the nurses,
um,
and then then the doctors tend to be a special breed.
It's not because many doctors are not comfortable with death.
They're not comfortable with not being able to do something to save somebody.
So you have to develop a lot of patients and a lot of acceptance.
You have to let go of your power to change things.
So it's deeply meaningful and deeply transformative work.
And,
uh,
you also have to work with a lot of people with multiple different attitudes,
life and there's religious,
non religious,
spiritual nonspiritual in denial and acceptance.
And all the stages in between.
So it was beautiful,
beautiful work.
And I,
I,
one of my highlights of my medical career all the same time I was still doing my
family practice.
And when did,
uh,
when did it focus on addiction or an uh,
an acute interest in addiction start to steer your medical practice?
So as a family physician I've always had substance addicts in my practice.
It's just a few.
And uh,
again it was an accident I got fired from I palliative care job.
My,
my argument is that I was fired for gross competence
or just too damn good at it but also for gross arrogance.
And in other words with my spontaneous and insightful and rather radical non
traditional style,
I could have great results and often did in palliative care.
If I may interrupt for one second would be or might be an example of your
approach that others thought was radical or something you would say or something
you would do with a patient.
That's that that got great results.
But that would seem very radical to others.
Well I would engage them in deep conversations.
Stuff would come up with,
it'll be painful,
but it'd be transformative.
Physically I would just use the methods that have not been proven but occurred
right to me.
And they've seemed to be helpful and helping people out of pain or dealing with
they shoes and so on.
Um,
uh,
I was very open and multiple approaches.
I wasn't just falling,
falling things by the book.
So that was my competence.
The arrogance was that I had a very busy life.
I was still delivering babies,
running my felony practice.
So I would,
I would get into palliative care.
And then then the nurses said to working with me,
it was like working in the eye of the tornado and other physicians who didn't
have my attitude or my particular mindset would legitimately question what I was
doing.
But I would regard all such questioning as an attack rather than as an inquiry.
And I would react like a bulldog was being threatened.
And that's the arrogance.
And that's what ended up leading me to be fired.
And it was a great firing because there's always,
I learned a lot about myself.
It took me a while,
but it took,
and then three weeks after I was fired,
I got this phone call from,
from our clinic and Vancouver's downtown east side.
Now the downtown eastside of Vancouver is North America's most concentrated area
of drug use.
We have more injection uses in this few swell book radius than anywhere in North
America.
So I get this call saying,
how would you like to come and work down here?
And this is three weeks after five foot of care.
Had I not been fired,
I couldn't have taken that other job,
which then led me to the high point for my career,
which is working 12 years with addicted population and eventually leaving family
practice and doing that full time.
So who,
or orchestrated all this,
I have no idea,
but it was a beautiful progression.
Something that's come up quite a bit in interviews on this podcast is some
variation of sometimes you need life to save you from what you want to give you
what you need.
Exactly.
And uh,
I think about that a lot.
At the very least,
it's a,
it's a pain relieving Lens through which to view events that unfold.
How,
yeah,
how do you define addiction?
Or maybe a better question is what is addiction?
And,
and along with that,
if you want to tackle it,
you know what her pour definitions of addiction or misconceptions.
Fair enough.
So in addiction is a complex psychological,
physiological process,
but which manifests in any behavior,
any behavior that a first sons enjoys,
that a person enjoys,
find some relief fan and therefore craves in a short term but suffers negative
consequences in the long term and doesn't give up despite the negative
consequences.
So craving pleasure relief in a short term,
negative consequences in the long term.
Inability to give it up.
No notice.
Say has said nothing about substances.
I said,
any behavior?
So it could be related to cocaine,
crystal Meth,
heroin,
fentanyl,
marijuana,
nicotine,
alcohol,
whatever.
Could also be sex,
gambling,
internet relationships,
shopping,
eating work,
extreme sports,
working out,
um,
for Nagaffi,
any number of human activities.
So I said,
any behavior.
Now the official definition of addiction and according the American Society for
addiction medicine is that this is primary,
it's a primary brand disorder.
It arises in the brain role largely due to genetic reasons.
This is how they see it.
And I say that's just not true.
Uh,
the other popular idea,
but addiction is that it's a choice that somebody makes,
that people choose to be addicted,
which is what the legal system is based on because if people don't like choosing
what are we punishing them for?
And,
and uh,
yeah,
so I,
although I think the medical definition is closer to the truth,
I don't see it as just genetic.
It's a genetic disorder and I don't see it as a primary brain disorders.
So let me perhaps show you why,
if that's okay.
So I give you this definition of addiction again,
craving relief,
pleasure,
short term,
negative consequences,
long term,
inability to give it up.
Would you be willing to tell them if you've ever had an addiction in your life?
I don't care what to do.
I'm not asking what.
Oh,
yeah.
I,
I can,
I can say yes and I can tell you exactly what it was.
I in high school,
so I saw,
I suffered for,
from what I suppose most people would consider depressive periods beginning
at latest age 10 and never found relief from that until I was
okay.
Competing in wrestling very seriously in high school all throughout high school
and an older teammate introduced me to a federal.
So the federal,
uh,
federal hydrochloride,
which for those people who are curious,
uh,
is,
well,
at least at one point ephedrine was found at the very least pseudoephedrine and
something called primatene mist used for asthma.
And I think they also mixed it with Guaifenesin.
Nonetheless.
The reason you cannot buy in many places,
large amounts of primatene mist is because people freebased it into
methamphetamine.
That's right.
So you have a federation,
which is a very strong stimulant combined with caffeine and aspirin.
And when you combine those three,
it's not an incremental increase in effect.
It's a,
I mean,
it's probably logarithmic.
It's a very synergistic effect.
Exponentially.
Exactly.
And he was recommending it for increased endurance.
And uh,
there there is some effect,
although it's also very highly thermogenic,
which wasn't good for me.
So it made me really hot,
which was already a weakness of mine,
but it ended up providing me with relief.
It was a very strong stimulant and I began to not only use it for sports,
but self medicate using it.
Okay.
So great.
So let me quickly ask you,
what did it do for you?
Relief from what?
Uh,
it's,
it's made me or at least contributed to a euphoria,
uh,
optimism,
energy.
So I didn't,
I didn't,
I didn't feel the symptoms of what I,
in retrospect,
I would call it depression,
the low lethargy,
uh,
the pessimistic lens through which I viewed things.
It seemed to magically just erase all of that in about 30 minutes.
So you've Forio literally means a good feeling.
Um,
it gave you energy,
it gives you,
made you feel good.
It made you up to a mistake.
Also improved sports performance,
right?
I'm not sure that are those good things or bad things to feel optimistic?
Those are all good things.
In other words,
the addiction wasn't your primary problem,
your problem,
the problem is that you depressed that you lacked a sense of wellbeing,
but you lacked energy.
Right.
So in other words,
the addiction is not the primary problem.
It's an attempt to solve a problem.
Right.
And then the real question is how did the problem arise?
In other words,
this is a rare,
my theory is that it's always rooted in shelter trauma and that the addiction is
an attempt to do deal with the effects of childhood trauma,
which it does temporarily while it creates even more problems in the long term.
Right.
Uh,
I would have one side question for you.
Given that estimate was your drug of choice,
this may not be true for you,
but do you think about the Spec?
You might've had ADHD as a kid?
Quite possibly because typically people with Adhd,
self medicate with stimulants because hardly tweeted age.
I'll be giving people stimulants,
Ritalin,
methylphenidate method.
And so lots of people that choose are stimulants of self medication like
nicotine and caffeine and crystal meth and Ephedra and are actually self
medicating idiot suits.
Very likely.
Yeah.
And I was punished by teachers for,
I wouldn't say not paying attention,
but being interested in other things in class.
So I remember very distinctly my kindergarten teacher,
I'll name her by name,
it's,
it's shameful.
Mrs Ms Bevin,
her,
Mrs Bevin,
I refuse to learn the alphabet because she wouldn't give me a good reason why I
needed to learn the alphabet.
It was just,
you need to learn the alphabet.
So she made me,
it's soap in front of the class and put me at the bad table.
She got with that too.
But I was always interested in doing many,
many,
many things.
And in fact,
the reason,
one of the reasons that I started wrestling is because I was very hyperactive
and is,
I believe the story goes.
Other mothers recommended to my mom that she put me into something called kitty
wrestling to drain my batteries before I got home.
So that makes perfect sense.
I've never been drawn to d depressants,
never been drawn to opiates.
In fact,
after surgeries,
uh,
I get very sick if I'm given Vicodin or anything like that.
So I've opted out,
uh,
have never personally had any issues with alcohol.
The,
a lot of people do.
It's always been a draw to stimulants.
And once the,
we don't have to go down this,
this,
this path cause I want to,
I want you to be able to focus on,
on these,
these definitions.
But,
uh,
where I got myself into trouble was having never been physically addicted to any
substance before.
I started using ECA stack once a day.
My friend was doing it twice a day.
I started using it twice a day and then I start using it three times a day and
you develop a tolerance very quickly,
right?
More and more.
And if you stop the withdrawal symptoms are of Sofa.
I had never experienced that.
So I continued after sports to use this.
And uh,
certainly in the long term there are some,
some very nasty side effects,
but I didn't stop.
I mean for many,
many years.
Well,
so there's a great link within 80 at the end,
addictions and not just because they both begin with the same three letters.
Um,
and I can tell you what my own ADHD and this is the way we go back to charter it
again,
so that tuning out,
that absent mindedness,
that desire to scatter your attention all over the place,
that's not a disease.
They say it's an inherited disease,
the hell it is.
That tuning out dad divided attention is actually,
but let me give you a personal question again.
If I were to become abusive towards you right now,
verbally or otherwise,
what would be your options right now?
I could
ignore you.
That's not what you would do first.
Is it not likely?
I mean,
I would right now I would probably just listen and pause.
I shut down often if I get attacked verbally because I don't want to respond
with rage,
which has historically been my response.
I hear you.
But uh,
but let's get a bit more basic about it.
The rational response,
if I were to become a new sieve would be for you to just,
uh,
a search yourself.
St.
Don't talk to me that way.
Right.
Or it would be to leave saying,
this interview is over.
And if for some reason you had not the strength to duty though those,
there's other people in the room here with us,
you could ask for help.
Right?
But what if you couldn't escape,
fight back or seek help,
then you would shut down or tune out.
Right now there's the tuning out is simply a defensive response on the part of
the brain.
And they'll put me back into my infancy when my mother's so grief stricken that
I'm crying cause she's in pain.
And I'll read you a quote here.
Find a yes please.
And uh,
this has to do with,
uh,
the,
the sensitive child.
The child is very open and can feel the pain and suffering and going on its
immediate environment.
The child is aware of his own body and can also feel the tension,
rigidity,
and pain in the body of the mother of an everyone else he's with.
If the mother's suffering,
the baby suffers to the pain never gets discharged.
The organism does not develop the confidence that it can regulate itself,
that things will happen the way they should.
Hanse lack of optimism.
Okay.
Now
Mama didn't abuse me.
She did her best to look after me,
but she was stressed,
depressed,
terrorized,
grief stricken
and picking that up as a sensitive infant.
Can I fight back,
change the situation or escape?
Nope.
None of those.
What can I do?
Nothing I can do.
My brain will tune out as a way of dealing with the stress.
So I'm not talking about abuse here,
I'm just dealing what?
Stressed mothering or panting.
The Chas Bandon will tune out.
When did the Cias Baining at tuning out when the brain is developing.
So the tuning out then becomes programmed is the default setting and that's why
Edd,
so it's not an inherited disease,
it's not a disease at all.
It begins as a coping mechanism,
which thing gets programmed into the brain and is a lot of these early quarter
mechanisms function.
They help you in the short term create problems in the long term.
And that's atds one of these examples.
And of course it also most more porn makes you more prone to be addicted because
now when you're tuned out,
life becomes a less interesting.
You shut emotional,
you protect yourself.
Now you feel depressed.
What does depression actually means?
You said you were depressed.
What does mean to depress something is to push it down?
Well,
do people push it down in depression?
The pushed on her emotions.
Why would they?
Because the emotions are too painful.
So even depression becomes as a coping mechanism.
You'll push it down so you don't feel the pain,
but then later on that interferes with your life functioning.
So it all begins as a coping mechanism and later on becomes a source of
dysfunction.
And all this is happening when the brain is actually developing,
which we can talk about later.
So,
um,
these are the links I began to make,
including after I was diagnosed with it.
So I,
and then despite the fact that a couple of my kids were diagnosed and knew that
this wasn't the genetic disease,
that what it is is actually is a coping mechanism and had,
which got programmed to the brain.
And then when I read the literature on brain development,
wow,
it turns out the human brain is shaped by the environment and particularly by
the adult child relationships.
And so it all began to make perfect sense to me.
There,
there are few things I'd love to underscore or reiterate because I think they're
very astute and very helpful.
Uh,
and certainly if I had had some of these reframes,
I think that,
uh,
I would have been able to be proactive with working on a lot of my own issues
much,
much earlier.
Uh,
me too,
by the way.
Yeah.
Uh,
for instance,
uh,
okay,
we can come back to this.
I'm actually just going to mention two things and then we can,
we can go where that takes us.
But the first is rather than asking why the addiction asking why the pain,
instead of looking at the,
the consequences,
looking at the causes and not confusing the,
the symptoms with the causes.
So instead of asking why the addiction,
asking why the pain and the the other,
this,
this might take a moment for me to read,
but I think it's worth reading and I should say that he had compassion for
addiction.
This is an organization cofounded by,
uh,
you,
yourself and Vicky.
I'm going to make a guess.
I've never actually said her last name,
but do lie or do lie.
Uh,
Vicky,
just for,
for context,
for folks who are wondering,
I was actually the very first person about five years ago to recommend that we
meet and then I took a note of it in a notebook I still have.
And that's part of the reason that I reached out for the book.
And
just because we may revisit this,
I met Vicky at a gathering at
the home of someone named George Sarlow,
right?
Who has a lot in,
who shares a lot of common background with you and certainly common interests.
But what we'll come back to that,
the part that I want it to read
is,
is the following,
and
I'm going to make my,
make an attempt here.
All right,
so the mainstream view of addiction,
you mentioned this to the clinical perspectives,
that addiction is a matter of individual choice,
moral failure or weakness,
which is why so many approaches are based on deterrence and punishment,
which includes,
uh,
self help approaches for that matter that,
that I've attempted myself.
The clinical view is that addiction is a disease of the brain with disorders of
brain circuits and behaviors and accurate yet narrow perspective.
So I think that's,
that's a really important align and accurate yet narrow perspective.
So perhaps accurate,
but incomplete,
right?
It is accurate that in the addicted brain that the addicted brain is
demonstrably physiologically dysfunctional brain,
but narrow because it seeks to explain the dysfunction in strictly physiological
and biochemical terms without recognizing the emotional and social component,
how the brain works.
And this was really driven home for me recently in the last several years I've
gotten to know Tony Robbins.
Yes.
And I attended an event not too long ago with several of my very close friends
called date with destiny.
And at this event
he asked the audience of a 5,000 people,
how many people here know someone who takes antidepressants?
Pretty much every hand goes up.
How many people here know someone who takes antidepressants yet is still
depressed and is probably 80% of the people who raised their hands the first
time.
And I personally know quite a few people who take antidepressants,
which,
uh,
seem to help on some level,
although the,
a tolerance for some of these pharmaceutical cause it can also be developed very
quickly.
And yet if,
if my experience is anything like the experience of,
or I should say if the experiences of other people's,
anything like my personal experience with friends,
let's say,
who have depression,
you witness these thought patterns and verbal patterns that can take them from
the highest high or just a,
a baseline of optimism and drive them back into depression.
And so they're just,
it seems to be just from an empirical or observational standpoint more to the
story.
Right.
So I,
I,
I really appreciate you putting into words what I've grasped to try to
understand and also convey.
Uh,
so with this definition of addiction,
how do you work with patients?
Well,
let's go back to what I said.
What'd you quoted me saying?
Not why the addiction,
but why the pain?
So if we understand that addiction in every case is rooted in some painful,
uh,
internal experience,
and that when you ask people what does the addiction do for you,
they'll say,
it numbs me.
It was the pain.
It makes me feel connected with other people.
It gives me a sense of control.
It gives me inner peace or the lack of inner peace,
the lack of control or the lack of connection.
They're all forms of emotional.
If I ask the question not why the addiction,
but why the pain,
then at least do an examination of that person's life rather than looking at
just at their brain chemistry.
San quoted from an article that appeared in the journal Pediatrics,
which is the official journal of the American Academy of Pediatrics.
It's about as specific as you can get.
2012 the article comes from the Harvard Center on the developing child.
Again,
a prestigious child development research institution at Harvard University.
This article did not present new information so much as it elegantly summarized
decades of research and notice what they say.
They see growing.
Scientific evidence demonstrates that social and physical environments that
threatened human development because of scarcity,
stress or instability can lead to short term physiologic and psychological
adjustments that are necessary for immediate survival and adaptation,
but which may come at a significant cost to launch them.
Outcomes in learning behavior,
health and longevity.
That's what I was saying before that there's early adaptations like pushing down
your feelings.
When the fingers are too painful,
we'll help you as an infant,
young,
young child,
but then they cause problems later on.
The tuning out that you do to to,
to protect you from the stress in your environment.
If you're very sensitive,
it doesn't take a lot of stress,
uh,
helps you and you are,
but in the longterm becomes the problem.
That's exactly what they're saying.
No,
a jump a few pages ahead to what they say about brain development.
Then this is so crucial and it's so crucial because they still don't teach this
to medical schools.
Even though scientifically is not even vaguely controversial,
the human brain develops an interaction with the environment.
It's not genetically programmed purely.
Here's what they say.
The architecture of the brain is constructed to an ongoing process that begins
before birth,
continues into adulthood and establishes either a sturdy or a fragile foundation
for all the health learning and behavior that follow,
not some of the health learning,
all the health learning.
And they'll notice what they say.
First of all,
the architecture of the brain is constructed through an ongoing process that
begins before birth,
which already means what happens in the wound.
Oh,
it is an impact on you.
So if you mother stressed and she's got high levels of stress hormone that's
already affecting your brain development.
And when you think of all this stress pregnant women out there,
no one who has seen so many kids in trouble.
And we know from Machen Studies,
international studies that when mothers are stressed,
uh,
their placenta will naturally have more cortisol and adrenaline and stress
hormones.
Those kids would be more likely to have stress.
She was later on abnormal special on levels,
even at one year of age,
behavioral problems,
learning problems and so on,
which tells us a law as to why adapted kids adopted kids have so many more
problems.
That's another issue.
But the next paragraph is key.
The interruptions of genes and experiences literally shapes the circuitry,
the developing brain and his critic.
Lynn critically influenced by,
in other words,
the circuitry that chemistry of the brain and which centers and with circuits
and which systems develop and which neuro chemicals will be presenting and what
quantities depends on the early environment and is critically influenced by do a
mutual responsiveness of adult child relationships,
particularly in the early childhood years.
In other words,
the most important influence shaping the physiological development of the brain
is the quality of parent child relationships.
And the one parents are stressed or distracted or workaholics,
like I was,
uh,
a young parent.
Uh,
if there is instability,
economic troubles,
relationship troubles,
unresolved trauma on the part of the pant,
loving parents who are just stressed,
that'll interfere with a child's brain development.
That's why we're seeing so much weight.
The HD now,
so much more waters and then so much for other problems because of stress in
theF and in society.
That affects the parenting environment.
In other words,
yes,
there's physiological problems with the brain,
but it's not a genetic issue.
It's really through the experience.
So when you look at brain scans of adults that are troubled brain scans,
as you do an addicts,
you're not just looking at the impact of addiction.
You also looking at the impact of Charter Toronto and chartered stress.
And this has been shown over and over and over and over again.
So there's no separation between the physiology and the psychology.
So if you come to me as an addict,
then you say,
I got such and such and I asked you what does it do for you?
When you say it numbs the pain that my question is where did you develop the
pain,
what happened?
And then we have an inquiry and not no longer becomes a shameful thing that you
chose this.
No,
doesn't mean that you stuck with it because you've got this genetic problem.
We get it as an adaptive response to something that happened and we can heal
that.
The reason why addiction treatment is failing is because physicians don't
understand is Dickie dealing with the effects,
which is the addiction and the behaviors,
which shows the effects of the addiction,
but not the cause,
which is the charter of distress and the impact of charter distress that carry
into adulthood.
You know,
there was hugs,
state prisoners of sheltered and so president methods of treatment in psychiatry
and addiction medicine and childhood psychiatry deal with the facts rather than
causes.
And this is where we're so ineffective at it.
I've,
I've many questions.
Yeah.
Uh,
so the,
the first is just to,
to underscore something,
which is,
you know,
the,
our software,
you know,
the genetics play a role but do,
but it's not a comprehensive explanation for what we're discussing skimpy
to suppose,
but they don't pay the tournament.
Right,
exactly.
No,
there were very few genetic diseases.
There's one runs in my family,
muscular dystrophy.
If you've got the gene,
you'll have the disease.
My Pimp,
my mother had it right.
That would be predetermined.
That just predetermined veverial to those diseases.
Okay.
Let me tell you an interesting study from either Australia or New Zealand.
They looked at a group of people for aggression.
They found that the most aggressive people had a certain gene variant.
You think they found the gene for aggression?
No,
they didn't because the least aggressive people in the group had the same gene.
So the most aggressive and the least aggressive shared the same gene as compared
to the average.
The gene could not have been for aggression.
No.
If you actually looked at the life histories of those people,
the most aggressive people had been brought up in troubled,
sometimes abusive,
but always very stressed homes.
The least aggressive robot brought in very nurturing homes.
What was the gene for sensitivity?
The more sensitive you are,
the more you're going to be affected.
When you brought up in a peaceful home,
you're gonna get that much more peaceful.
When you're brought up in,
in,
uh,
and a stormy home,
you're going to be that much more aggressive.
So there are these predispositions,
but then not for specific illnesses,
therefore,
temperament.
Right?
Which means that you're going to be more or less affected by the environment.
And so yeah,
there's some Peter's supposing juniors will be no,
both from animal studies in monkey studies and human studies that even you find
a gene that for similar reasons,
predispose somebody to addiction.
If that animal or if that human being is brought up in a good nurturing
circumstances,
their risk of addiction is no greater than creatures without that gene.
Right?
So it's just not a genetic disease.
And the fact that it runs in families,
it doesn't prove anything because,
you know,
as I always point out on a medical doctor and if two of my kids become medical
doctors of,
which is no danger whatsoever,
but if they did that wouldn't prove that the practice of medicine is a genetic
disease.
Right.
All right.
It's,
it's,
it's not a,
it's not a catch all explanation.
Also,
you have,
I mean,
because of a few of the books I've written,
I hear a lot of stories both successful and unsuccessful about people attempting
to lose weight.
And,
uh,
they'll often say,
well,
it runs in my family.
Like,
my parents are fat,
my grandparents are fat.
And they'll say,
do you have pets?
yes,
I'll say,
or your pets overweight.
And they're like,
yeah,
my pets are fat.
Okay,
well clearly,
clearly not just a genetic issue.
Well that,
may I say something on that?
Yeah.
But have you heard about the adverse childhood experiences studies,
the ace studies,
the average child adverse adverse childhood experiences study?
You know,
I haven't,
but I feel like there's a questionnaire
serious.
There's a test that you can take it.
There is,
so the address charter expensive studies were done in California,
but I think 17,
14 or 17,000 adults,
mostly Caucasians,
half of them university educated.
And to look at the relationship between childhood adversity and adult outcomes
and an adverse childhood experience was defined as physical or sexual or
emotional abuse at divorce,
at parent being jailed,
um,
violence in the family,
a brand being addicted that pending mentally ill,
a pant,
dying.
Um,
these were the main ones.
And for each of these adverse childhood experiences,
the risk of addiction goes up exponentially.
The risk of autoimmune disease go up there.
Just going,
depression goes up.
The risk of Adhd goes up.
The risk of,
uh,
relationship problems,
STDs,
everything goes up.
Now,
you know how these studies started,
these studies started an obesity clinic.
The Dr. Vincent Felitti,
uh,
who was a San Diego internist,
wonderful guy,
a deep thinker and researcher.
They noticed that at this clinic with rigorous dietary control and exercise,
they could help people lose weight.
But what even they couldn't do,
couldn't ensure they continue those here.
Here's when they'd live.
Exactly.
They couldn't help him keep it off.
And then Felitti did something that's,
I have to say is unusual for a medical doctor.
He listened to his patients and they said,
don't you get it?
We're stuffing down our pain.
This is all based on childhood trauma.
And so obesity itself is a response to childhood trauma.
It's just another addiction.
Uh,
I could talk about it in many ways,
but,
and the adverse childhood experiences studies have been repeated numerous times,
nine other countries,
all those with the same results.
And,
uh,
so that the obesity epidemic right now is not just an epidemic of junk foods
and,
and sedentary lifestyles.
That is true.
Yeah,
those are contributing factors,
but it's,
but the underlying basis as people self soothing the stresses in their lives.
And so it's really an epidemic of stress.
So let me return to another point,
uh,
or one thing you said in passing,
which I'd love to dig into a little bit and that was how at the time say the
example I think we were discussing.
Well,
actually before that,
let me mention one thing.
So I've had my entire g my full genome sequence,
a predisposition predisposition to alcoholism is very prevalent in my family
from a genetic standpoint,
just from a software basis.
However,
I mentioned earlier,
I never had issues with alcoholism,
with stimulants.
So,
uh,
just,
just as,
just as a footnote,
but what I was going to,
what I'd love to ask you and then I'd really love to hear what you do with
patients and once you start looking at their pain and the tools you use or the
approaches you use.
But
the one of the epiphany's for me in the last very recent,
a year or two has been looking at my coping mechanisms very differently.
And what I mean by that,
for very long time I had certain behaviors,
certain defaults that,
uh,
I hate it,
which of course means I'm hating a part of myself.
And that included anger,
rage responses,
uh,
use of stimulants,
you name it.
Uh,
uh,
a close friend of mine who is a therapist,
but I've never,
I've never engaged him as a therapist and a,
there are certainly plenty of bad therapists out there,
which I think is a separate topic.
Nonetheless.
He was helping,
and I'm sure we'll get back to this,
but in preparation for a very controlled supervise psychedelic experience,
he was helping a,
another friend of ours prepare is this with the Mvma?
This is with Iosco.
Okay.
And,
uh,
this,
this person had a number of addictions and she hated these addictions.
And she said,
I hate these.
I realized there they're terrible.
They've,
they've ruined my life.
They're ruining my life.
And it was all a negative relationship to these behaviors.
And he said,
did these ever serve you?
Did these ever help?
What did these do for you?
And she,
and she described how they helped her cope with very difficult circumstances
early on.
And he said,
perhaps what you should do as an exercise and what we can do is for you to
effectively thank those behavior for the role they played and for them the
necessity they filled.
And to then recognize,
you know,
thank them for their duty effectively,
but to let them go because they're no longer needed.
And that was a huge eye opener for me.
And I began to,
this has coincided with a number of things and I want to take us off the rails,
but began to use something called loving kindness meditation,
or met him.
I met a Emmy TTA meditation,
which was introduced to by a gentleman from Google.
Actually a formerly Google shade Manc 10 and then also Jack Kornfield,
who really reiterated for me,
of course,
but I never applied it to myself.
I always applied this loving kindness meditation to other people.
And what was recommended is that I apply that loving kindness to these two,
the younger Tim,
to the other versions of Tim who had these behaviors that I had grown to hate
and resent,
and to actually thank them for the role they played.
For instance,
that rage,
that anger was the fuel that got me out of Long Island and a where I grew up
there a lot of serious drug issues,
particularly with opiates.
And my best friend died of fentanyl.
Uh,
many of my friends are addicted to opiates.
I who I grew up with,
uh,
many have died and I got out because I was angry in part.
I think that was the fuel,
but that fuel ended up over the longterm being very corrosive,
but to,
in a way to reconcile myself with that,
I had to stop presenting it.
Uh,
and I suppose it's maybe more of a confession than a question,
but your,
your comment,
uh,
brought it to mind.
And maybe as a,
as a Segue,
I just love to hear,
okay.
And we can take it anywhere we want of course.
But once you have shifted the focus from why the diction to why the pain and you
start to work with someone,
what approaches have you found to help?
What tools?
Well,
so I very much solute your friends approach.
It's exactly what the approach I would take myself and
I call it compassionate inquiry.
So inquiry in a compassionate way.
Now why did I do this?
But why did I do this?
Right?
The first one is not a question,
it's a statement.
It's a self condemnation.
The second one is a question.
Hmm,
wonder why I did this.
Ah,
is soothe my pain.
And so what'd your fence said that it served you?
So thank it.
Love it,
but let go of it is absolutely right.
I call it the stupid friend.
The school was founded.
Is is is,
is,
is the one who helped you in a particular way at a certain time,
but it can't learn that that way doesn't function anymore.
Right?
Then instead of helping though,
it's hurting.
So it's a friend because it's what you're trying to help.
But it's stupid because this not learning that you no longer that three year
old,
that five year old or that 15 year old,
you know,
so this not,
this leads to the question of trauma because it's one thing to recognize that
all this originates in chartered pain.
It's quite another to transform that pain.
And for that we have to understand what trauma is.
So people often think that trauma is what happens to you.
So trauma is a divorce when you were small and your parents fighting trauma is
your mother's depression.
Trauma is your father's alcoholism.
Trauma is your parents argumentation,
traumas,
physical or sexual abuse or some loss.
Those aren't the traumas.
Those are traumatic.
But the trauma is not what happens to you,
the Traumas,
what happens inside you.
And as a result of these traumatic events,
what happens inside you is yoga.
You get disconnected from your emotions and you disconnected from your body and
you have difficulty being in the present moment and you develop a negative view
of your world and a negative view of yourself and a defense of view of other
people.
And these perspectives keeps showing up in your life,
in the present because they had the stupid friends.
And so the issue is not just to recognize what happened at 10 15,
30 however many years ago,
but to actually recognize that manifestations in the present moment and to
transcend them.
And how do you do that?
By reconnecting with yourself,
by restoring the connection with your body primarily and with your emotions that
you lost.
And once you do,
when you found these things again,
then you have what we call a recovery.
Because what does it mean to recover something?
It needs to find it again.
So what is it that people find when they recover?
The find themselves and the loss of self is the essence of trauma.
So the real purpose of,
uh,
of,
of addiction treatment,
mental health treatment,
any kind of healing is reconnection
for people who are listening.
And want to reconnect with themselves,
with their bodies.
For instance,
what recommendations might you have,
whether that's things they can do or resources they can can look to,
uh,
or both or something else?
What,
what recommendations?
Because I'm sure I could actually,
I'm 100% sure because I've had people come on and for the very first time on
this podcast,
talk about sexual abuse that they endured as children and what they did to help
recover from that.
Uh,
many people listening,
I am sure have addictions,
both traumatic past experiences and trauma.
What,
what recommendations could you make for them?
Sure.
So I want to say first of all,
that for trauma,
you don't need terribly traumatic events.
So there's two ways to look at trauma.
One is the bad things happen.
I shouldn't have.
We've talked about those.
But the other way get traumatized is when good things happen that should've
happened.
So if the good,
good thing,
it didn't happen,
that should've happened.
Sorry.
So when you look,
look at the trope of omission,
trauma of a nation with the parents,
not that they didn't love you,
not that they didn't do their best,
but they were too stressed,
traumatized,
distracted themselves,
then you'd get,
didn't get the kind of attention and the kind of acceptance and the kind of
attuned being with that you needed.
That itself can make a disconnect from yourself.
The child needs that acceptance,
that connection,
that attunement.
Our brain development requires it or emotional development demands it.
And when we don't get it,
not because the parents don't love us,
but simply because of their own issues,
we can also suffer that disconnection.
So that's what what I call developmental trauma.
Um,
and now how do we connect?
Well,
there are many,
many forms of therapy,
uh,
is very difficult for anybody to do this on their own.
Some people do it.
I certainly couldn't do it on my own.
I've needed a lot of help in terms of therapy.
Uh,
that helps you understand what happened to me.
And so that is,
there's a reason for it.
Uh,
so that not as if there's a reason for it,
then it's no longer me.
I'm not somebody to be ashamed of it.
I'm just,
somebody had developed along certain lines for some very good reasons,
but it's not in my deepest character and it's not who I am and I don't have to
be that way.
That's a relief to know.
It's also not that I'm genetically programs I'm doing to stay that way.
You know,
number one.
Number two,
you have to reconnect with the body.
There are various body therapies.
My friend Peter Levine and his somatic experiencing walking tiger,
is that what it is?
Waking the tiger,
kicking the tire,
we can attack it was his first book and he's written many wonderful books since
then.
Um,
uh,
so some sematic somatic experience and gives method is called,
but she developed this brilliant,
there was Emdr,
eye movement desensitization,
reprogramming,
uh,
which is a way of bypassing the conscious mind and getting through the emotional
brain and quicker than talk therapy by itself can do.
So it's combined with talk therapy,
but it takes you past just a conscious defensive egoic mind.
Um,
there is emotional freedom tapping that people do.
There's a various variations on that.
Um,
there is,
um,
there's motor sensory integration techniques.
Um,
there is,
then there was the traditional therapies like yoga.
Now Yoga was not simply a physical modality when it first developed.
Yoga actually means unity.
So the very essence of yoga is this,
to regain that unity,
not just with ourselves,
but also with the larger creation.
And so yoga,
when it's practiced in its intended way,
not just the hot yoga over you get a good workout.
That's great.
I'm not against it,
but I'm talking about intentional yoga with a meditative aspect to it,
which is taught by a number of disciplines,
uh,
bodywork of all kinds.
I'm just gonna hit pause for one second.
Do you practice yoga?
And if so,
what type do you practice?
So I have always said that was my ADHD.
I'm not a yoga person.
I can't do it until you're,
and a half ago I met actually a Yogi.
Uh,
his name is Saad Guru and uh,
he's an Indian Yogi with a big following.
I was very skeptical,
but I met the guy I know I have a 15 minute daily yoga practice,
which I did this morning before coming to the interview and has made an enormous
difference in my life with my ADHD mind.
I really have trouble just sitting there when they sit down on the meditation
cushion,
my mind is like all over the place,
but with the yoga,
which is more body-based,
uh,
I can stay much more present.
There's a meditational component to it.
Uh,
and so the answer is yes.
If you'd asked me 18 months ago,
I would've said no,
I support it,
but I don't do it.
But now I'm actually a very committed practitioner and it's really has made a
difference.
Is there a particular,
is it a particular type of yoga that people could Google or learn more about it?
Well,
so I'm not all yoga expert.
Then there's many forms of yoga.
The other people more knowledgeable than I am because recommend,
but the one I learned is called inner engineering and it's taught by either
Google or his followers.
Then you can look up in her engineering or engineering.
When I recommended it to France and others has been only being grateful.
Second,
highly recommended,
typically a,
there's to me what seems to be a cult or on the guy,
which I don't take too particularly,
but he's the genuine article in terms of having a deep experience and being able
to try and submit that experience to others and creating a practical system
around it.
So it's worked for me.
I'm not here to recruit anybody else,
but since you asking,
no,
it's just my,
my fence.
Ppreciate yeah,
well,
you know,
I'm not going to blame it on my fans.
I like specifics and my inner engineering,
you can look up online and it's taught here in the states and in Canada
internationally actually.
And I,
but I did interrupt you.
You're about to mention,
I think another technique,
modality that can help.
You talked about,
uh,
for instance,
the somatic experiencing,
Emdr,
emotional freedom,
tapping,
motor sensory integration technique or techniques,
Yoga.
And then there's something coming up after that.
Well,
about 10 years ago I began to work with psychedelics.
No.
If you're 15 years ago,
you were to ask me will ever be working with psychedelics as a healing modality,
I would have said you're out of your mind.
But then through a series of events,
I became aware of the potential role of psychedelics in healing.
And I've been doing work with them now for 10 years.
And they're another potent method.
Um,
they're not for everybody.
And I have to emphasize that whatever modality you choose of a sucky,
they're like nature.
You have to do it with adapt.
Practition is with deep integrity and deep knowledge and experience,
but in such hands and in such a context,
it's can be like a superhighway to,
to self awareness.
I'm not in isolation,
but it opens doors that otherwise might take years.
And so it's not unusual for me to conduct the psychedelic session with somebody
or a series of sessions either in a group or individual setting and had them say
that was like 10 years of psychotherapy and one day.
And I've had the same experience myself.
So again,
it's not to be isolated from other kinds of work and it has to be integrated.
But it's not a potent way of working.
And of course,
as I know,
you are personally aware,
there's an increasing movement amongst psychologist,
therapist,
psychiatrist,
medical doctors,
uh,
other healers to find ways of incorporating,
incorporating psychedelic healing in the larger therapeutic scheme.
Well,
you mentioned as it related to Emdr and some of these other techniques that you,
that you listed
that it is a potent way of bypassing the egoic mind and certainly,
uh,
psychedelics as literally mind manifesting.
That's right.
In that case,
uh,
are one very potent tool that or they are tools that have been used for
millennia in traditional or ceremonial context around the world for many
purposes,
but
including bypassing the analytical,
rational prefrontal Cortex,
uh,
in,
in many capacities that you mentioned a series of events and I will come back to
the psychedelics and ask you which you've chosen and why.
Sure.
Work with,
but if you can mention any of them,
what were the series of events that led you sure to best to psychedelics?
And 2008,
uh,
my book on addiction in the realm of hungry ghosts,
close and Congress with addiction,
what was published in Canada.
And very quickly it became a number one national bestseller,
subsequently published in the states as well.
And I was in a book tour and uh,
people could ask me,
what do you know about addictions?
And I was called as a treatment Iowa square being a proven or Amazonia and vine
that's made into a brew that has psychedelic properties.
I knew nothing.
The next speech or the next event,
somebody else would ask,
what do you know?
But I was going to do an addiction.
I finally started getting annoyed with it.
Like,
leave me alone.
I've just written a book.
I've spent years researching it,
my life experience and all kinds of,
uh,
scientific,
exploration went into,
it asked me,
it was something I know about
and then I realized that maybe the universe is knocking on my door and somebody
said,
did you know you could experience it here in Vancouver?
There was a Peruvian Shaman leading some ceremonies up in Vancouver.
So
who am I to say no?
And I jumped right in and I sat in this tent with 50 other people.
50.
Yeah,
it was,
that's how they set it up.
It's not what,
it's not what I recommend,
but that's how they set it up.
They play beautiful music and there was a little baby in the room.
Uh,
mother and dad were therefore the experience.
The baby was in the room and the baby was cooling away and tears started flowing
down my face.
And these are not tears of sorrow.
They were tears of joy.
And I got in touch with such profound love that I had never consciously
experienced before.
Okay.
And there were tears of love.
And it wasn't love for anybody in particular.
It was just love.
And then I saw in all the ways that I had closed my heart against love in my
life and high,
it'd be trade love in my personal relationship with my spouse and uh,
and,
and my children and in other ways.
So I just got this
experience of love as something profound and,
and,
and universal and,
and a life defining.
But something for my just being cut off in so many ways.
And I got it
because
I closed my heart against love besides,
because when I was vulnerable,
small,
I'd be so hurt.
I went to my mother's states of mind.
She couldn't respond to me when I need it to be responded to.
Not Her fault,
but she couldn't.
And then when I was a year old,
she gave me to a stranger to save my life.
And I didn't see her for a month,
which is a huge,
explain that for a second.
The slogan is Budapest,
Hungary,
Second World War January,
the Russians are,
I've circled Budapest and on our fighting,
the Germans,
the government in is a right wing fascist,
antisemitic
military force.
And even though the depredations of Jews had stopped,
the German sit down,
I laid,
had half a minute and hunger.
Andrew was in three or four months,
but now the Hungarian fascist for killing Jews in Budapest and including in the
house where my mother and I were living.
So my mother gave me through a stranger in the street acquistion woman,
cause she didn't know she'd be dead or alive next day or that I would be,
and I was quite sick.
So I didn't see her for a month,
which I experienced is a deep abandonment halls could expense it.
So my heart's closes against love and uh,
I got all this.
And so I got that.
If this plant,
this plant that as you say and manifest the mind can show me both the ways in
which I've closed off from myself and that I don't need to because the love is
still there.
What healing potential it has.
No,
I wish I could say that after that experience,
I became a loving husband and our loving her and being,
I didn't,
uh,
it's not that simple as my wife could tell you.
Uh,
nevertheless,
it opened the door for me and I got right away.
Now.
However,
the thought that I had was that I had no induction.
I had had no introduction,
I had no processing afterwards.
Iosco is a medicine or plant that has been used in the Amazon basin for hundreds
of years,
maybe longer in its cultural context,
in a tribe in the village where people know each other,
where they know the Shama and where they share the same assumptions in the same
history.
That's not the same as a bunch of Westerners,
strangers to each other come together for one night drinking and stuff and then
going their separate ways.
So immediately the question that came up for me,
it was how can we create a setting that at least resembles as best you can,
um,
fashion the original setting.
So we came up with the idea of where we treat,
where a small number of people get together with properly chain Schamens who
have integrity and experience deep experience and with me facilitating people's
preparation and their post ceremony integration.
And so I've been doing that now for 10 years and a lot of learning involved,
you made mistakes,
but it evolved.
And the essence of it is that people don't come into it cold.
They come into the preparation in a safe setting where pretty soon a group
becomes a family to each other,
which means that none of that they love each other and support each other,
but they also trigger each other.
I mean,
I may basically,
I tell people,
I guess what,
you're back in your family of origin and everything you've hated about your
feeling urgent just going to show up here,
but in the context where it's safe for that to happen.
Right?
And so I've seen lots of great healing.
I've had people with multiple suicide attempts heal from depression.
I've seen people get much better with the autoimmune diseases.
I've seen,
uh,
people deal with all kinds of addictions and,
and,
and life issues,
relationship problems come out of it,
much more themselves,
much more able to deal with these issues so long as the proper integration is
done afterwards.
So that was my personal experience.
No.
That then,
um,
introduced me to the whole world of psychedelics and I realized the,
there's a lot of research being done these days.
There's this organization,
uh,
maps,
multidisciplinary Associated Association for Psychedelic Studies,
which is a group of psychologists,
psychiatrists and medical doctors,
therapists,
counselors,
uh,
interested people to study scientifically,
the role of psychedelics and healing.
And as you're probably aware,
interesting studies have been done around psilocybin mushrooms and endo life
anxiety studies had been done,
which are revolutionary and using MDME assisted psychotherapy,
MDME being the medical name for a technical name for ecstasy,
again,
in the right setting with the right leadership,
these have proven to be very powerful modalities of healing.
And so there's a whole new resurgence of psychedelic research,
uh,
in a number of different areas.
Some of them manmade,
some of them are plant based.
Um,
but there's a whole world that I was introduced to and uh,
I've learned a lot in the last 10 years.
And,
uh,
again,
I,
uh,
both practice it in my own healing work and,
um,
I'm interested in it also as a participant.
I'd love to add a few things to your second comment and then ask a bunch of
questions about the first.
Yeah.
So for people who are interested in learning more about the current scientific
studies and mechanisms of action related to some of these compounds and what is
being done,
there are a number of
very interesting and a very competent organizations as far as I can tell.
Maps is one that you mentioned and I'll actually be seeing,
uh,
the founder Rick Doblin in just a few days time.
There is the halftime institute.
Yes.
Which I've worked with primarily run by MDS and PhDs or at least the board and
so on is comprised of of scientists,
medical doctors.
Uh,
it was through the Hafter foundation and also directly with Johns Hopkins.
So I've had some involvement with the [inaudible] with psilocybin studies.
And actually thank you too many of you serve at smacking the mic.
Too many of you in my audience who helped through a crowdfunding funding
campaign to raise funds for a study at Johns Hopkins related to a treatment,
a treatment resistant depression until seven.
So after institute,
excellent organised organization to look into.
And then you sona also,
uh,
which I believe is primarily focused on Psilocybin,
whereas maps at this point has done great work on many levels,
including helping to facilitate MTMA being designated a breakthrough therapy and
effectively getting fast tracked into phase three trials.
The FDA.
That's right.
Yeah.
And these are all organizations that I would encourage people to look into a,
and
it's really an exciting time and also a fragile time as it relates to these
compounds,
which have certainly demonstrated historically,
uh,
accepting Mtma.
Let's just look at the studies.
Many of which were done starting and say 50s and 60s,
looking at the clinical efficacy of using these compounds for everything ranging
from alcoholism to nicotine addiction to many of the things that you mentioned
brought your daughter what is little known,
but a Bill Wilson,
Dr Bill who founded one of the funders of Aa,
right.
Actually had some powerful LSD experiences.
Yeah.
Um,
and which helped him in his,
in his spiritual growth is an aide.
I don't talk about that very much,
but it's a fact,
if I may parenthetically say as much as I support the 12 steps with a also
doesn't tend to talk about is the trauma that first causes the addiction.
And Bill Wilson himself was a traumatized child.
He was abandoned by his parents and he was very young.
And so it's interesting that a,
for all the good work that it does do,
which I support,
I don't support people being forced into any spit to go from the treatment.
But as a self chosen form of treatment,
it can be very helpful to many people,
but they don't talk about two very interesting things,
which is,
when is the SEC Delyth part and the other is the Toronto part.
Yeah.
It's
for me just looking at my own childhood experiences and uh,
exploring recovery defined as you define it in,
in the last several years,
especially in last six months,
it's been a fascinating and frustrating to discover and try to piece together
these various elements.
Uh,
but the,
uh,
what is the frustrating part?
That there is a,
well there may,
it may exist,
but I couldn't find one stop shopping that checked all the boxes.
Right.
So they end any,
right.
So,
so it's,
it's been an exercise in collecting various tools and piecing them together.
Like you said,
you have the AIA does incredible work and then they,
what they've done in terms of a distributed free service with social
accountability and support is incredible.
Absolutely.
Uh,
the psychedelic component,
which bill actually wanted to as I understand it,
make one of the steps in a,
uh,
needless to say,
it was hard to get widespread leadership support for that.
Uh,
and then you have the trauma piece.
So these are all tools in the toolkit that people can use for their own sort of
be spoke approach in some respects.
Coming back to the IOWASCA specifically,
and I,
and I should just as a caveat point out because I do think that these tools,
I know these tools are very powerful.
I have firsthand familiarity from past experiences and,
uh,
have,
have been very engaged with this scientific community for some time now they can
be misused.
Uh,
there are many charlatans.
unfortunately there's more than,
there's many.
There's some very powerful healers,
Shamans who unfortunately exploit people sexually and financial,
very common.
And this is of course not just restricted to the Iosco rolled a,
it's also happens in the spiritual world.
How many spiritual leaders with tremendous power,
tremendous healing influence of at the same time exploited men and women and
created all kinds of,
uh,
um,
further trauma.
So unfortunately,
when you have that much power and you haven't totally done your integration
work,
you can start misusing using that power.
And that happens in all of the healing modalities as we know,
but it certainly happens in the psychedelic world as well.
Yep.
It's very,
it's,
uh,
I wish I could say it's rare.
It's not a,
but it's something to safeguard against,
especially when you're in that vulnerable state.
So I would actually recommend that people see a documentary called Kumaré,
which he is very much worth watching.
And,
um,
the brief overview is it's an Indian filmmaker who begins studying various gurus
and healers in the u s uh,
in,
in hopes of,
I believe the original impetus was to simply do a documentary on charlatans.
And then he went to India and he said,
they're just as bad here.
And he said 99% are just as bad or worse.
And he decides to make himself a guru as a,
as an experiment.
And it's,
it's a very thought provoking documentary that I think will,
should,
it becomes a kind of fake guru,
right?
That's right.
And remember then he unveils it.
Yeah.
I don't want to give too much away,
but it's very well done.
Very worth watching because it helps to prepare you,
I think psychologically too,
uh,
not lose yourself in a dangerous way.
And here's the problem.
You see what I said about the essence of trauma is that you
use,
you lose connection to yourself.
And that means you lose connection to your gut feelings,
right?
As long as you've got fillings out with you and you honor them,
they'll protect you.
But the very essence of trauma is the loss of that,
which means that when you lose connection to the gut feelings,
then you're very vulnerable to being exploited.
And when you talk to people who were exploited in any context,
psychedelic or not,
if you ask them,
do you have any kind of vague sense that this is not quite right,
they'll say,
yeah,
but I didn't listen to it.
And the fact that they didn't listen to it is already a marker of trauma.
So since it's traumatized people,
which is most of us who seek healing,
it's also vulnerable people who seek healing.
And this is what some of these people can exploit.
Um,
so the very portal into healing,
which is opening up the vulnerability that we've shut down against,
is also the portal for potential laws.
So people have to do their due diligence.
And I'm not trying to create paranoia here,
but people just should be careful.
You just mentioned something that I,
I'd really love to just pause and emphasize.
Uh,
you mentioned a few things.
So number one is that,
or your gut feeling slash physiological intuition can help you.
Uh,
and that's something that for many reasons I completely muted or ignored for a
very long time.
So it's been a process of getting reacquainted with that.
And I would say two things that,
uh,
that I've found helpful.
And if you have any comments on second in particular,
I'd love,
love to hear.
One was dramatically decreasing my caffeine intake,
which I found was almost like turning up the volume on static.
It made it very difficult for me to read or feel that's of their things.
That's,
I was using it,
uh,
maybe for many reasons,
but it had the side effect at least of muting.
Maybe that was why I did it subconsciously.
Many of these feelings.
Uh,
the second was,
um,
in fact a video that was recommended to me,
but it,
it corresponds to a book called the gift of fear by Gavin de Becker.
Uh,
and who actually owns a company that,
uh,
does protective services and executive security.
So you have to keep in mind,
maybe you don't always want to ask a barber if you need a haircut.
So keeping that in mind.
Uh,
it,
it also in brief points to the benefits of some of these
reactions are emotional states that we are prone to labeling negative.
Yeah.
Uh,
and,
uh,
the,
as you said,
not to make anyone paranoid,
but rather to inform them these are currently,
uh,
existing risks.
And one of the hopes certainly with say,
ultimately better researching these compounds after they've been,
uh,
really unfairly but for understandable reasons,
politicized and put into the same schedule in the United States is heroin and
cocaine to have them rescheduled so that they're prescribable if then that
happens,
the ability to certify therapists to regulate and to maintain a broad type
quality control goes up.
So that's also one of the hopes is that that will decrease the likelihood of bad
actors,
uh,
and allow appropriate punishment for bad actors.
It's you,
as we know,
even in legalized legitimate professions still happens.
This stuff happens.
It's still on.
It's still ultimately,
you know,
gut feelings are still the best response.
And let me address first why we shut down our good feelings,
if I may please.
So,
yeah,
a human being has two fundamental needs apart from the physical needs in infancy
and childhood.
One is for attachment,
not attachment is the closeness and proximity with another human being for the
sake of being looked after or for the sake of looking after the other human
beings as mammals and even birds.
Oh,
are creatures of attachment.
We have to connect and attach because otherwise we don't survive.
If there's nobody that's motivated to take care of us to attach to us that way,
and we if not motivated to attached to others,
we just can't survive.
Okay.
One it is,
and the thing is,
is that the endorphins which,
um,
at the end of the body's internal opiate and make,
uh,
chemicals,
which heroin and all the other opiates of resemble,
okay.
They helped to facilitate attachment.
So if you think infant mice and you're not out their endorphin receptors,
so they don't have endorphin opiate activity in their brain,
they won't cry for help and separated from their mothers Bushman me that they
would die in the wild.
And which goes back to what happens in early and chart to the,
when there's stress and trauma,
these,
uh,
these endorphins systems don't develop.
And then when people do heroin,
it feels like a warm,
soft hug to them.
They feel love and connection for the first time.
That's why it's so powerful.
Yeah.
But so we had this need for attachment without which obviously the human infant
was the most hopeless,
the most dependent,
at least mature of any creature in the universe at birth.
Uh,
yeah.
You cannot survive without the attachment and that attachment relationship,
given that we have the longest period of development of any creature you know
well into adolescence and beyond.
Okay.
Attachment is not a negotiable need.
Okay?
But we have another need which is
authenticity.
Alto,
the self means being connected to ourselves,
just knowing what we feel and being able to act on it.
So that means I've got feelings.
So let's look at a human beings evolved for hundreds of thousands of years and
forth.
A hundred thousand years or so of this species existing on earth.
How did we live?
We didn't live in cities and houses.
And so on.
We lived out there in the wild until very recently in human existence.
Now just hold on.
Do you survive in the wild if you're not connected to your gut feelings?
Not Very Long.
If you start using your intellect instead of your gut feelings,
you just don't survive.
Yeah,
so that's a powerful survival need as well as the attachment is a survival need.
Authenticity is a survival need.
But what happens if your authenticity threatened is your attachment
relationships,
for example,
is a two year old.
You get angry because you didn't get that cookie before dinner,
but your parents can't handle anger cause they grew up in homes when there was
rage,
a holism and they're terrified at the very expression of anger.
So they give you the message that good a little kids don't get angry.
The message you receive is not that good.
Look is don't get angry,
but the angry little kids don't get loved cause your parents are not salon.
They won't look at you.
They talk to you in a harsh way.
You're not getting loved,
not experiencing love at that moment now,
but you've got to stay attached.
Guess what?
You're going to suppress the authenticity every time.
And this is hubby lose connection to ourselves and to our gut feelings.
So that strangely enough,
that very dynamic,
which is essential for human survival in a natural setting,
not becomes a threat to our survival in this,
in this more modern setting,
we have to stay authentic,
is to threaten attachment.
And so we give up our authenticity and then we wonder who the hell of you are
and whose life is this and who's experiencing all this and this life doesn't see
know,
and who am I really?
And so that's where the reconnection has to happen.
That's where the healing happens is that that reconnection,
but it's because of that conflict,
that tragic conflict in childhood between authenticity and attachment that most
of us face,
that we lose ourselves and lose connection to her gut feelings.
There's so many directions we could go with this.
Uh,
and I'm really glad you shared that because that had an enormous,
that observation has had an enormous impact on,
on some of my close friends.
And that's something I was only exposed to really today because,
uh,
our mutual friend Vicky recommended that I ask you to expand on it.
What I'd love to return to if we can,
can I say something?
Yeah,
of course.
Sorry.
In this building does a picture of Elvis Presley.
Yes.
So there's a song of his that I play at my retreats or,
and my events all the time.
It's called.
Anyway,
you'll love me no matter how it goes.
I don't like actually played for you,
but it goes anyway.
You love me.
That's the way I'll be,
uh,
in your hands.
My heart is clay.
I'll be strong as a mountain or a week as a
willow tree.
Avi.
Powerful.
I'll be like a little baby any way you want me.
That's how I will be now.
That's considered a love song.
It isn't.
It's a lack of loss song.
It's a song that says chest attached to me.
I'll give up anything about myself.
Just accept me the way you want me to be.
So if it's a sad song and when you hear him sing it,
this deep sadness in it and some of the power of Presley as she came from his
own suffering,
he wasn't just singing a song,
he was actually infusing it with all the emotions of loss.
So even though it's presented like a love song,
it's actually a song about the loss of love.
And that's the situation of the infant who says,
just love me.
I'll be anything you want me to be.
And that's the,
uh,
that's the tragic conflict isn't an attachment and authenticity to see.
Yeah.
So this ties into exactly where I was going.
Uh,
which is related to your pre and post work with psychedelics.
Yeah.
And for people who are watching this or listening to it,
I'm returning to this,
not because I want to hammer home psychedelics.
They're not for everyone.
And in my experience,
the vast majority are,
should say in my observation,
the vast majority of psychedelic use is very irresponsible.
Uh,
and,
and I would not recommend,
uh,
because
it can,
it can certainly cause a good amount of harm if not done in a supervised safe
fashion.
But the pre and post work
okay.
Could apply to many modalities.
I mean it,
it does in this case,
this example that we're about to talk about apply to psychedelics,
but it could,
yeah,
and correct me if I'm wrong,
but it seems like it could very easily apply to going into any intense or
unusual modality.
Oh,
like VIP pass and I'm pushing the pasta like this date with destiny,
Tony Robbins,
I,
I mentioned,
which is certainly intense and very,
very different.
Very powerful.
That's why I'm coming back to this.
Uh,
but we can discuss it as it applies specifically to psychedelics and even
specifically to Iowasca if that is the primary,
uh,
that's the primary compound we're talking about,
which is really just for people who are wondering.
It's a,
one of the reasons I,
Alaska is really tricky is that it is unlike say,
I'm going to get off topic for a second,
but it's still on topic.
It's not quite like,
uh,
mushrooms.
And what people consider the primary psychoactive molecule of psilocybin.
It's a bit different.
It's more of an old fashioned,
it's like if you go to a bar and you order a vodka soda,
pretty much everywhere you go.
And Soda.
Yeah,
very similar.
Yeah.
Assuming the poor is the same.
Iowaska is more like an old fashioned.
There are few ingredients that are almost always there.
So if you go to,
let's say I want to say God bow or other parts of Bidu,
it's going to be mostly the Ios SCA vine plus a plant called Chacruna.
Yeah.
Or a psychiatry.
A vdd switch is a DMT I think.
Guess,
suppose it must be nn DMT campaign,
uh,
containing plant,
which is made orally active through the Maa oh inhibitors.
Monoamine oxidase inhibitors in the vine.
How they figured that out is a whole separate story,
which is kind of wild.
Uh,
the plants told them is the short version.
I know,
although I have a science scientific fan who gave me a starting these simple
explanation,
which,
oh,
okay,
well let's actually makes more sense to the western mind.
What is it?
When I was improved,
they also told me the plants told us,
which on some level accept.
But,
but I just want to say something here because we're talking in an extended way
about the psychedelics.
I don't quit the impression that this is most of my life or work.
It isn't.
I do this stuff one or two or three weeks a year.
So it's not like the major part of what I do.
But it is a very interesting part because it illuminates everything else that I
do.
Uh,
in a sense that it goes very deep.
Now,
this scientific friend,
when the science friend of mine says,
actually they were,
let's say using the ios going,
boiling it up,
because I have a square itself though.
The vine has some secondary private and on its own without the Chacruna.
Yeah.
Very strong auditory.
So then what happens is some leafs of sugar Buena Fall into it.
Hmm.
Inevitably overheads of years that's going to happen,
they say,
oh,
well this combination is even more powerful.
So it need not be as esoteric as it could have been.
A rather simple discovery.
So who knows what the real story is,
but in any case,
the preparation and the processing.
So I'm just going to add
to that,
which is,
that is one combination you then also have in certain regions of,
and it's found in other places outside of Peru from us,
certainly in the largest Iowasca as sacrament based churches are actually out of
Brazil.
Um,
but the,
it can also be Iowasca vine plus [inaudible],
which is a different plant.
Also DMT containing,
but a,
a,
a for some people,
substantially different experience.
And then the only reason I'm mentioning this is so that people are aware of why
I am particularly concerned when people are cavalier about,
hey,
my friend's ordering some Iowaska from Hawaii and we're gonna put it in a slow
cooker and have it at his house this weekend.
I'm like,
bad,
bad idea.
Many,
many centers,
even a well intentioned centers in,
in Bidu.
We'll also put other things in the brew because they think that want more of x.
So they'll put coca leaves or put,
so think cocaine,
coca leaves,
they'll put toy,
which is even,
uh,
the Twitter,
which is even scarier in some respects.
Coca,
not that scary.
Uh,
so just be aware that when you say Iowasca not you,
but when people think ios guide is not a standardized dose that you were getting
the,
I was at a retreat in Costa Rica where really four different nights stayed
ceremonies in each time with a different concoctions.
Oh God.
So one night with the Peruvian shoe people tradition,
uh,
preparation one night with the okay.
From Columbia.
Yeah.
And you know,
it,
it's who prepares it,
homage.
They bullet for what combination,
uh,
what intention and so on.
So that's by and large true.
And really,
um,
the people I've worked with,
the,
you know,
this is all this,
not that it's always the same drink every night,
but it's pretty much the same preparation.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
so I,
I took us down a little rabbit hole,
but the,
the question I have is with all of your clinical experience in recognizing that
this is a therapy,
but it's an adjunct therapy,
it's not used in isolation.
Yeah.
And you've through trial and error and design come to a place now where you have
maybe certain best practices or approaches to the pre,
pre and post work.
Could you tell us about either or both of those are,
you know,
ideally maybe exercises or questions people could think about it
on their own.
I know nothing,
it's,
it's hard to recommend that and isolation perhaps.
But I'd,
I'd love to hear any,
any details that you're willing to share about the pre and post because it's so,
so important to just,
it's hard to,
for me,
at least in my limited experience,
even to overemphasize
specifically,
um,
we just not the only with ELT I work with,
but did that specifically,
there's a physical preparation,
for example,
no caffeine for a period of time.
Uh,
no red meat cutting down on salt,
um,
uh,
excluding dairy products.
So there's a physical preparation just to cleanse the body and then to make it
more receptive to the Ios car.
Um,
from the emotional and psychological point of view,
you want somebody to really form an intention what I actually I want or this
experience because intention is everything.
So it's not like I'm going to take this stuff and let's see what happens and why
am I here for why am I coming?
What is my intention and growing there?
What do I want to find out?
What issues am I working with?
So intention setting and then,
and really considering
what is my purpose and undertaking this,
uh,
this experience.
Cool.
When people arrive,
we don't just plunge into ceremony.
And my Iowa scurry,
we have a day and a half of groups preparation.
So everybody articulates their intention,
why they're there and we'll be dk deeply explore how that intention arised a
rose,
sorry.
And what in their lives brought them to this point and what issues they need to
deal with.
And
my way of working is to get people very deeply to their core issues,
uh,
which they may not be even aware of.
But again,
to this process I called compassionate inquiry.
And this is true whether I'm working with plants or not,
they,
they get to to see what it is that they're really seeking and what are they
seeking.
They're seeking themselves.
They're seeing the connection ultimately,
but there's steps that you go through.
And then we helped them to set a specific intention for that,
uh,
first ceremony.
And the specific intention is what do I want to learn tonight?
Not just what I want to learn in general,
but what I'm gonna learn tonight.
Some people want to learn about,
tell me about my fear.
Okay.
Uh,
teach me about
my pain.
Um,
show me what love is.
Show me what courage is.
Show me what my strength is.
See,
it's not that the ILS code that comes with an agenda,
uh,
eh,
it works through you and it manifests,
was sent you so that your intention,
the more specific it is to you where you are in life at that moment,
the more effective it's going to be.
And then the Sharma's work with you doing a ceremony and they chant to you based
on what they're picking up from you at that moment.
Uh,
they work with you on a genetically,
sometimes their work hands on,
uh,
as well.
And uh,
you both have your own experience and you share the group energy
and then people go to sleep and the next day and then the following day,
we then process,
well,
what happened to you?
What the,
what the visions came to.
You know,
some people hold the visions,
some people with more prosaic line,
it's like me.
Well,
all the,
every got divisions.
I,
I did originally got the vision is,
but it's been years since I've seen anything.
Uh,
some people will have bought of the experiences.
Some people go to him in intense emotional states.
Uh,
which in my view are always a memories of,
of maybe forgotten memories,
but in dwelling memories of,
of very early experiences,
intense.
Some people have beautiful entities coming and teaching them,
you know,
jaguars and anacondas or various angelic entity is,
I've never been blessed with that.
Then,
uh,
I used to get frustrated,
but actually whatever experience you have,
that's the expense you need to have.
And,
and for me it's not about the visions or it's about what is
the teaching and the teaching is always there.
And the purpose of the processing is to help you find the teaching that was
important to you by whatever experience you had.
Not about comparing your experience to the night before or two nights before or
to the experience of other people.
It's your specific experience.
What does it mean in your life?
So this is post a retreat then,
uh,
again,
um,
whether you do a program like the past and would you do the landmark forum or
whether you to do a Hoffman process or whether you do any kind of
transformational work or a meditation retreat.
If you don't integrate what you've learned into your life and you build up some
practice around it,
it's gonna become a memory,
a nice memory
lab best,
right?
Yeah.
Straight back into making hypercritical decisions impulsively 12 hours later.
Awesome.
Absolutely.
Very destructive.
So the more integration we can and and,
and the gentleman in the psychedelic work,
this a question of integration,
is it becoming a more and more recognized and,
and,
and more and more practiced.
So integration means keeping in touch with people that can help you stay on
track,
keeping in touch with the goop that you shared,
the experience with,
uh,
putting some practice into your life.
Let's just journaling and meditation.
Yoga,
perhaps you,
you're going to return and do some more plant work or perhaps you won't.
That's entirely up to you.
There's no prescription to be made there.
But the point is to go from experience that is a discrete and time limited to
some kind of integration that is,
that happens over time.
How do you format that,
that integration,
are you interacting with the people on your retreats once a week for four weeks
or you have two sessions and the following week?
What is the actual format look like?
Well that's evolving and that's different for different people.
But um,
in general I would say that if you can talk to somebody regularly over time and
if you can maintain your contact with the group,
so they're like a Facebook group,
Facebook group where people share experiences.
If you take on certain practices and you do them together,
or at least you do them simultaneously.
And then you talk share about practices.
Um,
these are all forms of integration,
which,
and we've,
we've mentioned this a few times,
applies to more than just the modality of using plant medicine.
Absolutely.
So after this,
that sound like broken record,
but this is very recent.
After going to this Tony robins event with a number of people including a,
we have photo online.
So I think he's fine with me saying it.
Joe Gabia,
cofounder of Airbnb,
Marc Benioff,
the CEO of salesforce was sitting right behind me.
He was part of the group,
but he's a friend,
at least an acquaintance getting to know each other.
In any case.
Uh,
we kept a group texts grid,
uh,
going afterwards to hold each other accountable and also to set followup group
calls and so on.
Uh,
a number of things I'd really like to underscore because uh,
you mentioned them and,
and I'd like to reiterate their importance and also how they transcend the
premise and work the psychedelics.
The first is
you mentioned intentions and uh,
I'll just,
I'll just share my experience and also a number of recommendations that helped
me tremendously with plant medicine work.
But then life in general,
which is you set a clear intention but the clear intention is not the same as an
expectation.
That's right.
And if you go in to and you have an expectation you can't let go of,
that's right.
You end up,
many people end up trying to white knuckle the experience.
And that's true in general in life and is very true for plant experiences
together that this is going to happen.
That's got this should happen.
And some people sit there the whole night visiting their experience because it
doesn't meet their expectations.
Right?
So there's,
there's a,
there's a
card.
It's a little car that I was given as a gift,
which I didn't come to appreciate fully until maybe a year or two ago.
I've been carrying it a long time and it was given to me by an ex girlfriend.
It's a,
and it says the tax,
the task,
which hinders your task is your task.
And See,
you mentioned a few things and he said,
well,
that is the work for that night.
And uh,
I've come to know a few people I respect as,
I hesitate to use the word,
but are because they're really only two or three people I have personally met.
I would feel comfortable calling a,
a Shaman,
uh,
and they all have minimum 10,
15 years experience in a traditional apprenticeship setting.
And,
and,
and by the way,
that means deep personal work.
Very deep.
He's sitting in the jungle by yourself being bitten by mosquitoes and doing that
means drinking,
uh,
various plans,
tobacco and other plants,
not beyond Ios run.
And really preparing,
I know somebody on that path right now.
Let me tell you,
very deep.
It's deep committed work.
It's not for the fainthearted.
I would never do it.
Yes,
very intense.
Very,
And I mean there,
there are people do 15 months of isolation,
dieting,
various plants,
no sex and assault and the pork and red meat.
You know,
you know the drill we won't get into right now.
And uh,
what,
what they've,
they've shared a few examples with me
of say I,
I've never,
well that's not true,
but I,
I have always in the past shied away from large groups.
That's why I was taken aback back with mentioning 50 people.
Uh,
but uh,
it is,
it seems very common in any group,
especially larger groups.
And this is true in psychedelics or at Vipassana retreats.
They actually,
the nickname for it that was given at the,
the day silent retreat I did at spirit rock was the Vipassana vendetta where you
decide that someone who's sitting close to you is coughing too loudly or clears
their throat too often or whenever.
And it starts to,
you start to perceive,
read and think about it incessantly and maybe get angry about it.
And instead of watching your own reaction instead of watching your reaction and
they're the example that was given to me by this,
this,
this particular,
uh,
I'm just going to say Ios Gatto to simplify things.
Iowa skittle,
someone who works with Ios guy was,
uh,
he told me about this,
this,
this Westerner came down,
I guess.
I guess they're kind of Westerners to there,
just south of the border.
So Northern American who came down and was furious that someone in the group
wouldn't shut up with their screaming.
He was just furious about this.
And there are a number of ways an organizer can handle that.
But he,
he took the guy outside and he said,
that person is your work tonight.
Absolutely.
And if you think about that reframe
and how to view something that perhaps historically you would respond to as a
problem or an annoyance or offensive to view that.
And there are certain times when you have to fight and stand up for yourself.
I'm not saying you shouldn't,
but I think that in my case and in the cases of many folks,
we fight too often.
We wear ourselves out.
We get upset too often.
How can you view that as a gift?
How can you view that as a your work?
Can I again give you a quote?
Yes,
please.
Which I love.
It's one of my,
from my,
one of my favorite teachers and uh,
his name,
his age allness and he says,
you'll conflicts all the difficult things.
They're problematic stitchers situations in your life or not chance or haphazard
there.
Actually yours.
There's specifically yours designed specifically for you,
about a part of you that loves you more than anything else.
The part of you that loves you more than anything else has created roadblocks to
lead you to yourself.
You're not going,
you're not going to go in the right direction unless there's something fricking
on the side saying,
telling you,
look here this way,
that bothers you.
Love you so much.
That part of you loves you so much that it doesn't want you to lose the chance.
It will go to extreme measures to wake you up.
It will make you suffer greatly.
If you don't listen,
what else can it do?
That's its purpose.
And I found this to be true,
a physical illness and mental problems and everything.
You got to see what is the teaching here.
So we can look at all these things as problems to get rid of,
which is what the personality wants to do.
Or we can look at them as learning opportunities,
which is what you're to self wants to do.
Now,
two things.
One is you talked about intention in life.
So my wife and I had a holiday recently in Costa Rica.
Partly it was the working holiday,
but partly it was just a holiday.
Traditionally we've had terrible times doing holidays,
partly because my workaholism and once I go into a holiday,
I just collapsed.
And now my wife is dragging a corpse around.
You know,
because,
because I'm a workaholic,
you know,
and I hadn't cleared a space.
So,
so this time we actually want to do the holiday with intention.
This is nothing.
It was like the Alex just to do it,
that we set an intention,
what is it,
our intention and if we have an intention,
I've learned from a couple of very wise teachers what structures,
who want to set up to support our intention and how are we going to handle when
there's kind of disagreement or conflict.
We had a beautiful holiday because it was the first international holiday that
we've had.
So that intention in life in general is absolutely essential.
Like every morning,
what is my actual intention?
You want to do a bit of an exercise and,
sure.
Okay.
And then you know,
if you don't like it,
just tell me when was the last I,
this is something I do in my groups or when I speak or in the summer.
Um,
and I teach,
so I,
yes,
I asked people to tell me some recent episode when they're upset with somebody
with their lives and something that they are open to sharing.
So it doesn't have to be anything sorted or thing,
but just something,
you know,
whether it's your spouse partner,
the bus driver,
I don't care what,
sure.
A friend.
Okay.
So are you going to do with it?
I can share anything.
It just where you were upset with somebody.
Okay.
Yes.
So what happened?
Describe it.
What happened?
Yeah.
All right.
There were a number of issues in my home broken,
uh,
aspects of the home,
things that were falling apart or needed to be fixed physically.
Physically.
Okay.
Yeah.
Right.
And I had hired someone to do these things right while I was gone and I came
back and none of them were fixed.
Okay.
And your emotional reaction was anger.
Rage.
Anger.
Okay.
Anything else besides anger?
Yeah.
Hmm.
I think they're close cousins.
Okay.
Frustration.
His anger.
Yeah.
I was disappointed.
Disappointed it.
Sadness.
Yeah.
It's a different feeling.
So I was disappointed in myself also because I started to look at how maybe,
well,
this appointed is,
is not so much any emotion as a state of mind and asking what the emotions were.
I'm like,
what's inside?
Disappointment.
Okay.
Sung,
it didn't happen.
I want it to happen.
How do I feel?
Okay.
Isn't there a sadness there?
Sure.
Yeah.
There's sadness.
I'm not talk you into it.
I'm just asking,
I suppose I'm,
I might be confusing state of mind and states of mind and emotion since I'm not
sure how to do something.
What I'm looking at.
The raw emotion.
Yeah.
Sadness.
So there's anger and sadness.
Those are the emotions.
Let's,
let's go with that.
Okay.
So I'm going to ask you a silly question.
What were,
you said an Andrea bug.
Okay.
Well,
I suppose the answer,
which is not the right answer I'm expecting was I was angry that someone had
made commitments to me and not fulfill those commitments.
Okay.
That's what happened.
They had made the commitment in the phone,
but that doesn't tell me what you were sad or angry.
Well,
okay.
What,
what,
what does that mean?
That they didn't fulfill their commitments?
Uh,
meant that they didn't care about me.
They didn't have that respect.
So they didn't care about getting to know,
respect you.
What kind of person doesn't get cared for?
Respected
[inaudible]
I might need a lifeline here.
I don't know.
Someone who doesn't deserve to be cared for our respective,
exactly.
Somebody unworthy.
Right?
Sure.
Over respect then and,
and care.
Okay.
Now
if two other people here,
which there usually are,
when I do this exercise,
I would ask them,
okay,
we just listened to a Tim.
Tell us about this experience.
Are there other reasons why this other person might not have done the work that
has nothing to do with him or her not caring of a tam or not respecting him?
So what other reasons might there be
1,000,001 with my name on it.
He could have,
he could be in the hospital,
be in hospital,
are cared.
One could have been in a car accident.
Exactly.
Uh,
he had a flight delay and got caught on Puerto Rico during a hurricane.
Yeah.
He's got ADHD.
Uh,
he and he can't follow through.
He's under stress and he couldn't.
Right.
Dude.
Okay.
The email that I was supposed to send a sitting and drafts and I thought I'd
sent it,
but in fact you never received it.
I mean,
okay.
And any number of possibilities.
Yeah.
No,
of all the possible use that you've just outlined.
Okay.
Including that they don't care about your respect you,
which is the worst one,
the one I immediately defaulted to.
Well,
I mean the worst,
it's bad.
I don't know.
But internally,
yeah,
internally.
The worst assumption.
Yes.
The one that I immediately made.
Exactly.
So let's notice something.
Hey you,
I should say we,
because we're all like this,
we don't respond to what happens.
We respond to our perception of what happens.
Right?
Okay.
That's what the Buddha said.
It's with our minds are created the world so that,
um,
if you'd find that the Adhd or,
or,
or you have a stressed or,
you know,
you might've been sad for him,
but he would not have been angry and you will not have been said,
okay.
Uh,
you,
you might've,
you know,
so first of all,
we don't respond to what happens to respond to our perception of what happens to
her interpretation of it.
I'm just got number one,
number two of all the possible interpretations.
We choose the worst one.
Yup.
Number two,
certainly what I just said isn't true.
We didn't choose it.
It's not like you went through all this
possibilities and you said it wasn't multiple choice.
I chose option don't or he doesn't care about me and he doesn't respect me.
He didn't do that.
You brain jumped there automatically.
Right.
My question is why.
Yup.
All right.
Here's the learning first time in your life that you felt hurt and angry that
you've been,
you've received
somebody didn't care about you.
I didn't respect you or has it happened before?
This is where the exercise might,
might,
might go sideways.
I'm going to hit pause on that.
I think that's probably for more of a conversation,
number one.
But you'd probably agreed it's not.
The first time is not the first time.
Very good.
And most people I talked to,
um,
it goes back way back.
Yeah.
This goes way back into childhood.
Okay.
And that's what trauma is.
We don't respond to the present moment.
We respond to the past.
No,
but along the lines of where discussion,
it's a beautiful learning opportunity.
No.
You get to know now what if you assume for a moment that you're the most
lovable,
most worthy of care,
most worthy of respect,
person in the history of the universe.
And this guy doesn't do your home.
What's your response?
Any number of the other options,
which does not trigger.
Yeah.
And intense,
negative,
emotional state.
All of those other options would trigger that.
So something in use,
I would argue,
still believes that you're not worthy of care and respect.
And that's what's gets triggered.
So who's the one that doesn't care about you and who's the one that doesn't
think you're worthy of respect?
No,
it'd be me.
It would be,
you know,
that's a learning.
No,
it is.
And this is exactly what you're talking about.
You're saying how these difficult things,
how these problems are always teaching opportunities.
And that's the beauty of healing is that when you reframe things and you,
and you actually see the source within ourselves,
all of a sudden that's liberating.
Because guess what?
If you're feeling that way because this guy did this or didn't do that,
that makes you a victim.
Yup.
But if you see that you are the source.
Yeah,
no,
you're powerful.
Yeah.
You're empowered.
You are empowered.
Is that,
this is something that a friend of mine here in Austin,
uh,
Robert Rodriguez recently said to me in a very similar way.
I mean it was,
it completely different context.
He was actually telling a story about someone else who was constantly blaming
people for everything in the film world.
And he said,
if you are the victim and you're,
and it's everyone else's fault,
you're powerless.
And he's,
we keep in mind every time you're pointing a finger at someone,
and I'd never heard this,
I,
I know it now after the fact that there are other people who have said this,
but he said every time you're pointing a finger at someone,
keep in mind that there are three fingers pointing back at you.
Exactly.
And I thought about it.
I was like,
wow,
that's just a good,
that's very sentenced to keep in mind.
No,
this is a recording studio sometime.
Was it this the,
yeah,
they do recordings.
The record in the past,
I just,
I just did the Johnny Cash every record here by any chance that,
you know,
I don't know if Johnny Cash was over here.
It's Po.
I would say it's possible because I spent around for a long time.
The reason I ask is cause he's got a song song
that I play at all my events.
It's going to in your mind it's called,
this is all goals done in your mind is on the soundtrack of dead man walking.
And He,
I think he wrote it himself.
It all goes down in your mind and it goes one foot in the fire,
w one foot on Jacob's ladder and other than the fire,
it all goes down in your mind.
So whether you are going to hell or it to you on the way to heaven,
it all happens up here,
which is such a powerful teaching cause this is what we can work on.
You know,
if we've,
if we're victims of the world,
uh,
Ramana Maharshi was a great Indian,
a guru.
Um,
he said something like,
if your foot hurts when you walk outside,
you can do two things.
One is the rep,
the horror world in Burlap,
or you can get a pair of shoes.
You can see yourself as the victim of the world and trying to change the world
so that they won't hurt you anymore.
Or you can actually empower yourself.
Yeah.
And that's what the heating is.
Oliver.
Well,
I will say the reason I wanted to have you on now is because I've been so
focused on trying to navigate these things myself over the last several years,
but most intensely over the last several months.
And I wanted to,
okay.
You ready to have this conversation with you and,
and how you doing so far?
I'm great.
I'm doing very well.
I think I'm the,
the sanest and a arguably in the best place I've been maybe ever.
So I feel very good.
That's very good.
That's w which means that,
okay.
That he didn't,
he just,
this is just available.
It's just possible.
Yeah.
You know,
I,
I got an email a few months ago
from a woman called [inaudible] now Hermann goring was the chief of the
Luftwaffe under Hillary.
Got It.
That's right.
I'm just wondering where I knew that name.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and he was the head of the Gestapo,
just,
uh,
an opiate addict,
by the way.
And a very clever,
very ruthless man.
Okay.
His great niece sent me an email a few months ago,
the thanked me for my work and she's been through her own process.
Imagine the Karma she was carrying.
Yeah.
And all the healing she has had to do.
So there was a grant,
her,
her great uncle tried to kill me and my people,
and there's the great niece making contact with me.
And to me,
it just in your example,
in my example and the example of so many people I know,
it's not like I'm a big piece of cake,
you know,
it's going to continue as long as I live.
But I experience internally the goodness and the healing that's available to us
and I didn't use to,
and I,
and I used to think I could help you,
everybody,
but,
but that I have was beyond hearing myself,
at least that was my belief,
know,
well,
let's put my corporate for the last 10 years.
Okay.
It just ain't true.
Um,
and anybody listening,
I just wanted to know.
It doesn't matter what state of mind you're in,
doesn't matter what you're experiencing.
It's human.
It,
uh,
it is,
tries,
mutable.
It is transformable because that to solve that you got disconnected from,
it's still available to you.
So it's not a question of just talking about what happened in the past.
It's a question of how do we connect to ourselves and what you're describing
about your own state.
If,
if,
if I can put it in one sentence,
you'd probably agree with me that you probably are much more connected to
yourself than used to be a hundred percent a hundred percent an SDS and SDS.
We requisite.
I mean,
that's,
that's why I feel the way I described exactly.
Gabor,
I really want to encourage people to learn more about you and your work.
And there are,
so there are certainly a number of places they could start.
Where would you suggest people dig more deeply?
Is there a particular book of your books you would suggest they start with?
Is there a particular social media handle where they can pay attention and learn
various announcements and uh,
see what you share of your work and others?
Well,
thanks for asking.
The simplest thing as my website ww,
Dr Gabo,
that data column,
D R,
G A,
B o r,
m,
a,
t,
the calm,
where am I speaking?
Events and I travel lovey and North America and five countries abroad.
Uh,
this year,
um,
my speaking events are listed,
uh,
chapters in my books are available,
right?
It was about my books,
articles.
I've been,
I've multiple talks on Youtube that people have filmed and posted seen by
hundreds of thousands of people.
Um,
I have a Facebook video that somebody that about my work that's been seen 12
million times now.
Uh,
so there's all kinds of ways to discover me on Facebook,
on Youtube.
At my website and I would also really hope that people check out my books,
um,
of whichever.
Then for,
uh,
the first one,
the American title is scattered and it's about Adhd.
And I wrote it after my own diagnosis and pretty much what I've said earlier
that I don't see it as an inherited disease.
I do see it as a response to family,
multigenerational and social stress insensitive children.
People say you're blaming the parents.
I'm not blaming the parents.
Uh,
I'd only in myself,
but I know how stressed my family was when I was a workaholic doctor.
Um,
and so that's my first book.
And um,
when you say,
well,
why are we looking at the percentage of kids with ADHD going up so fast?
It's not an a genetic problem.
Jesus don't change in a population over five or 10 years.
It's a social problem as much more stressed in the culture now there's much less
connection in a culture now and less connected people are.
And the more there is,
the more pressure there is unsensitive kids.
So that's scattered.
And other parenting book of mine is the work of a brilliant psychologist friend
of mine,
Gordon Neufeld,
Dr Neufeld,
who is the world's leading development psychologist.
As far as I'm personally concerned,
and I say that advisedly and the book is called hold on to your kids.
Why parents need to matter more than peers.
That's been published in over 20 languages now and it's about the fact that
since kids needs attachment,
the attachment need is the primary drive that we have and we've talked about
that.
It's like a duckling.
When a duckling hatches from the egg,
the duckling would be first to attach an imprint on the mother duck,
but what will he do if the mother duck is not around?
He'll imprint on a toy or a dog or a horse.
Our kids,
because the parents are too distracted and stressed in our society and and not
aren't so much anymore physically as during human evolution,
now find themselves in the company of other kids.
Guess what?
They imprint on their peer group and now you have immature creatures influencing
each other in moderately and this happens through the social media.
It happens in personal contact.
And as that happens,
the parents get pushed into the background,
they get more and more frustrated.
Now they get more authoritarian or they just give up and kids therefore don't
grow up.
They don't mature and they develop all kinds of problems.
Not because the parents don't love them,
but because simply because in this culture,
the connection between the kids and the parents have immediate disturbed.
And how do we store that connection is the subject of hold on to your kids.
So three of my books that are water on my own,
this one I wrote with Gordon,
uh,
my next book,
which is an a mindbody unity and health and illness.
And that's a conversation you and I could have another time,
but again,
where I showed that cancer,
autoimmune disease,
als,
multiple sclerosis,
Parkinson's,
colitis,
Crohn's disease,
chronic fatigue,
fibromyalgia are not accidental and separate physical events.
They had to do with the scientifically proven fact
that mind and body can't be separated.
And when things happen emotionally,
they will also happen physiologically.
In fact,
it can't be any other way.
And that the emotional system in our brains and our bodies and part and parcel
of the same system that also governs the immunity Norridgewock neurological
response and hormonal response.
And therefore when our lifelong patterns of emotional repression,
when people have to suppress themselves,
you know,
what the main thing and their attachments that 11 negative impact on their
immune system and the hormonal apparatus and the nervous systems as well.
And that book is called when the body says no exploring the stress disease
connection and has been published by over in over 20 countries internationally
as well,
including in the U S my file into my mind.
My favorite book,
uh,
is the most recent in the realm of hungry ghosts,
close encounters with addiction,
which explores addiction,
not from a point of view of a disease model or a choice model,
but how it is a response to a childhood loss,
stress and trauma and how to address that and also sort how to deal with,
like if you look at the United States right now,
you know what the facts are.
The most common cause of death under the age of 50 is now overdose.
And in the U s every three weeks do you have the equivalent of a nine 11 interns
every three weeks and nine 11 in terms of the number of people dying or where's
the public outcry,
whereas the resources,
whereas the political will,
whereas the mobilization of the media and and all the public health energies
compared to what happened after nine 11 and we're having this every three weeks
and why?
Because the treatment profession,
the medical profession and politicians in the legal profession does not
understand trauma and its relationship to addiction.
The average medical student doesn't even hear the word trauma and four years of
education doesn't even hear the word,
let alone get a lecture on it,
let alone get a course about it.
The stuff I told you about brain development is still not taught in most medical
schools.
So we have this response to addiction,
which is just dealing with the effects,
the behaviors,
controlling the,
the manifestations and not dealing with the causative factors.
That's why people don't get better.
And if you look at why right now is because social stresses increased,
economic insecurity is increased,
you know,
look at where do the opiate overdose happens more.
It's where areas where there's despondency and despair.
Totally.
And so that's the book in the realm of hungry ghosts that are not lots of my
talks on youtube,
but I think the best hub to check all this stuff out is my website.
And I hope to generate a podcast,
a regular podcast fairly soon.
If the people around me can twist my arm strong enough and organize me well
enough to do it,
there'll be a podcast.
And um,
I hope that will be up soon.
But knowing myself,
I don't want to make any promises,
but that'll certainly be listed on my website if it happen.
And could you give your website URL one more time?
Okay.
Doctor Gobbler Matt Day
and Doctor Garber,
mata.com and uh,
to everybody listening and watching.
There's the camera.
Uh,
I will also put that in the show notes.
So for everyone,
everything we've discussed,
the books,
resources,
organizations,
everything including your website,
which will be at the very top,
will be listed in the show notes,
which you can find at tim.blog/podcast and there'll be right at the top soil and
all of that will be very easy to find,
uh,
just in closing and we may very well end up doing around too at some point.
It wouldn't surprise me.
Uh,
even if it's off camera,
certainly we'd love to spend more time together.
Uh,
do you have any final closing words or a request or suggestion to the audience,
anything for people listening that you would like them to consider after they
finish this interview?
Uh,
okay.
Um,
I hope people will listen to you in a very personal sense,
not just as a,
an interesting experience,
but as possibly pretending to themselves and that the discussion with you will
help people look at themselves in maybe a new way,
um,
with what I call compassionate inquiry.
So rather than self judgment about stuff that went wrong or
they did to themselves or others,
they get curious.
What made me do that.
They get fused compassionately because we were all born in a send them.
We're all born.
Just want it to be loving and loved and then something happens and then it's,
it's a hard road back.
But I hope that this conversation helps people reconnect with that path or,
or,
or encourage them to continue on it.
And then secondly,
not to see it as an individual issue.
It's a social issue.
We live in a society that really does disconnect people.
And so it's not just an individual problem or an individual family problem,
it's multigenerational.
We never even talked about the mulch energy,
multigenerational nature of trauma,
but it is,
uh,
you pass this on from one generation to the next,
not because we intend to vote because we can't help it.
So it needs to be looked at in deep over the generations and broadly as the
function of a whole society.
Now let me give you one quick example,
if I May.
Sure.
A study last year showed that American black women,
the more experiences of racism they have,
the greater the risk of asthma.
And what does that tell us?
What a gift would it be?
Give people to,
to,
to control their asthma.
We give them inhalers that contain a copy of adrenaline and a copy of cortisol,
the stress hormones and other,
there was asthma.
Everything's everything to do with stress.
I'm not going to the scientific details now.
I could,
but it won't.
But it shows this question is the asthma Mac black woman an individual disease?
What does it a dysfunction of entire society?
And obviously it's the ladder so that the Buddha said that was at the many,
that cannot be the one I thought the one that cannot be the nanny.
And he talked about the interconnected core rising of phenomenon.
So we are social creatures.
Our brains are wired together.
Dr Dan Siegel talks about interpersonal neurobiology.
We're not isolated creatures.
So what have you dealing with?
You have to look at not just the individual internal environment,
but also the broader social and cultural environment of which you are one
particular manifestation.
And as our mutual friend Joe Polish,
so for MP wants,
we need to change the conversation around these issues,
particularly as for example,
on addiction from a blaming and shaming and ostracizing and just medical model
perspective to one that takes into account trauma and social issues,
image beings compassion into it.
And that must be the same for our mental health issues as well.
And whatever we look at,
we have to look at both the individual and the broader context.
Thank you for that.
And you mentioned
how we all begin loving and wanting to be loved or needing love and then
something happens and it's a hard road back.
And what I'd like to add to that is it's a hard road back,
but it's a worthwhile rode back and it is possible to find your way back.
If you had told me that a year ago,
I would have completely dismissed it,
but I'm in different place now and I would just like to thank you for helping
people to navigate that and it's very meaningful work that you do.
Thank you.
Thank you for taking the time today as well.
Oh,
it's a great pleasure to speak with you.
Thank you.
And to everybody listening and watching,
as I mentioned before,
definitely also visit the show notes.
Revisit this.
This is not a one and done something you listened to and then you go on as if
you never heard it.
Please look at the show notes.
Look at Gabor's work,
and you can find all of that@tim.blog forward slash podcast and to everybody
listening,
I would just say,
as always,
thank you so much for joining.